HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER WE HAVE FIFTEEN
BILLS ON THE CAP ON THE CALENDAR
TODAY THE FOLLOWING FIVE BILLS
ARE ON CONSENT.
SB TWO TWO EIGHT BUT JACKSON SB
FOUR THREE SIX FURTADO AS BEFORE
BY THREE HER TITLE.
SB FOUR SEVENTY SKINNER AND SB
SEVEN THREE FIVE LEYVA.
OF WE HAVE SENT SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR GROPING
SPECIAL ORDER TODAY.
THIS BILL MUST BE HEARD AND
SENATE JUDICIARY TOMORROW IN
ORDER TO MEET LEGISLATIVE
DEADLINES THEREFORE WE WANT TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE SO THAT WE CAN PULL ON
THIS BILL.
WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW.
SO US SEVEN CAN YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
RITA.
YEAH HER TITLE HERE STEM.
DOWN HERE BELL.
BELL HERE JACKSON PAN WIENER
[inaudible]
WINNER HERE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SO -- FOR THIS BILL -- AND
REPORT VOTE TO THE DESK FOR
MEDIA REFERRAL TO THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS A SECOND AMENDMENTS
OFFERED BY THE JUST JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE -- WHICH WILL BE.
PROCESSED BY SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WE WILL NOT BE
CONSIDERED ANY MOMENTS THIS BILL
TODAY BUT WE WANT TO WELCOME YOU
HERE TODAY SENATOR GROW AND
PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN.
THANK YOU MEDICARE HACKETT
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND I'M SURE I
APPRECIATE YOU LETTING ME
PRESENT THIS BILL TODAY.
LET ME START OFF BY SAYING
THINKING AND THE TEAR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
I KNOW THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS --
AND I GAVE THE CHAIR MY WORD
THAT I WOULD ACCEPT THESE
AMENDMENTS TOMORROW JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THAT WOULD DELETE
SECTIONS ONE AND FOUR PERTAINING
TO THE WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION.
AND THE P. R. A. SECTIONS OF MY
BILL.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SAY -- SHOULD
THE BILL ADVANCE I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ARE
CASH TO ADDRESS THE REMAINING
CONCERNS THAT ARE TO HAS ON THE
BILL.
I'VE BEEN A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR
THE DISABILITY AN INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITIES IN SIZE IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
AND AND WHEN THE DISABILITY
UNITED OR DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED APPROACH ME ABOUT
INTRODUCING THIS LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD INCREASE TRANSPARENCY
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE STATE'S
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS.
I WAS MORE THAN HAPPY TO
INTRODUCE THIS BILL.
SB SIX EIGHTY THREE WILL HELP
ADDRESS MORE CONSUMER ACCESS
INFORMATION ON THE INTERNET FOR
PROVIDING DATA.
IN IN MACHINE.
READABLE FORMAT FOR THE REGIONAL
MACHINE READABLE DATA MAKES
INFORMATION MUCH MORE DIFFICULT
TO ACCESS AND ANALYZE -- WHICH
DIMINISHES THE LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY IN THE SYSTEM AS A
WHOLE THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THE REGIONAL CENTERS TO CONFORM
WITH THE WEBSITE TO STANDARDIZE
FORMAT.
AND IT'LL ALSO HELP WITH
UNIFORMITY BETWEEN THE TWENTY
ONE REGIONAL CENTERS AND THE
CONSUMERS TO THE CONSUMERS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS CAN EASILY ACCESS
A INFORMATION IS MADE PUBLIC.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LONG STANDING
CONCERNS AMONG CONSUMERS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS REGARDING THE
REGIONAL CENTERS ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY AND HOW BOTH
MIGHT BE IMPROVED SB SIX EIGHTY
THREE WILL HELP.
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THOSE CONCERNS
AND WILL HELP.
AND AND WILL HELP MOVE WITH THE
DISABILITY AND DEVELOPMENTAL AT
SYSTEM TO STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION WITH ME TO TAKE TO
TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX EIGHTY
THREE IS ALISON MARANTZ
REPRESENTING THE SPONSOR
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE -- MY NAME
IS ALLISON MARANTZ -- I AM A LAW
PROFESSOR AT STANFORD AND ALSO
THE MOTHER OF A THIRTEEN YEAR
OLD BOYS SIR BY SAN ANDREAS
REGIONAL CENTER -- AND I AM HERE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY VOICES
UNITED -- FOR WHICH I AM A BOARD
MEMBER -- SO I WERE A NUMBER OF
HATS AND I WANT TO BRIEFLY TOUCH
ON THEM TODAY IN MY REMARKS --
NOBODY KNOWS BETTER THAN
PERRANCE -- V. CRITICAL AND
CLOSE CONNECTION BETWEEN
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY --
IF YOU CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEY'RE WHAT THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS OUR TO WHICH YOU KNOW
YOU OR YOUR CHILD OR IF YOU'RE
ITSELF ADVOCATE TO WHICH YOU CAN
YOU ARE ARE -- THEORETICALLY
ABLE TO ACCESS THEN THERE'S NO
WAY IN PRACTICE TO HOLD YOUR
REGIONAL CENTER ACCOUNTABLE FOR
PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS.
SO THE FOCUS OF THE PROVISIONS
OF TODAY'S BILL THAT I'M GONNA
FOCUS FOCUS ON HAVE TO DO WITH
TURNING THE THEORY OF
TRANSPARENCY INTO THE PRACTICE
OF TRANSPARENCY.
BY WHICH I MEAN WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF DISCLOSURES NOW THAT THAT
HAVE EEN MANDATED OVER THE
YEARS I CAN GROW UP TO MORE THAN
TWENTY FIVE NOW.
MORE THAN HALF OF WHICH ARE
NUMERIC HEY NATURE.
HOW MUCH MONEY IS BEING SPENT
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE BEING
SERVED -- AND WE HAVE.
TO REALLY FESTERING AND AND AND
REALLY MAJOR PROBLEMS WITH I'M
TRANSPARENCY.
EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE THESE
IMPORTANT DISCLOSURES THE FIRST
PROBLEM IS.
EVERY REGIONAL CENTER CAN DECIDE
FOR ITSELF WHERE THEY PLACE THAT
INFORMATION ON ITS WEBSITE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIND A GIVEN
DISCLOSURE IS LIKE GOING ON
TWENTY ONE INDIVIDUAL SCAVENGER
HUNTS.
ON TWENTY ONE WEBSITE.
I'M IN MY CAPACITY AS A LAW
PROFESSOR AT STANFORD I HIRED --
TO TOP RESEARCH FELLOWS WHO ARE
SKILLED IN DATA SCIENCE IT TOOK
THEM TWO WEEKS TO GO THROUGH THE
TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS.
AND IDENTIFY EACH OF THE
MANDATORY WEB BASED DISCLOSURES --
AND THEY CLASSIFY THE ABOUT HOW
HARD THEY WERE TO FIND IN A
NUMBER OF THEM WERE EXTREMELY
HARD TO FIND SOME OF THEM WE
STILL CAN'T FIND -- AND REMEMBER
THESE ARE DISCLOSURES THAT
CONSUMERS AND OTHER ADVOCATES
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS READILY IF THEY CAN'T
ACCESS THEM IN THE SYSTEM IS
TRANSPARENT ONLY IN NAME WITH
REGARD TO THAT PARTICULAR
TRANSPARENT THAT PARTICULAR
DISCLOSURE.
SO THE UNIFORMITY PROVISION IS
CRITICAL SO THAT ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
SYSTEM IS FUNCTIONING CAN GET ON
TWENTY ONE WEBSITES.
AND READILY ACCESSIBLE PIECE OF
INFORMATION THEY NEED -- THE
SECOND IMPORTANT -- PIECE WE
DISCUSSED IS THE MACHINE
READABLE FORMAT SO SO THINK OF A
PDF VERSES AN EXCEL FILE.
RIGHT A MANSION DOZENS OR
HUNDREDS OF NUMBERS IN A PDF --
DOCUMENT THE YOU HAVE TO
ACTUALLY TRANSCRIBED BY HAND
INDIVIDUALLY TO IT TO MAKE ANY
SENSE OF WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING
ON SYSTEMICALLY.
RIGHT NOW THAT'S THE STATUS QUO
ESSENTIALLY NO INFORMATION
THAT'S AMERICAN NATURE PRODUCED
BY DDS OR OUR REGIONAL CENTERS
IS PROVIDED NOW IN MACHINE
READABLE FORMAT.
SO THERE'S NO WAY TO DOWNLOAD
INTO AN EXCEL SPREADSHEET TO
MAKE COMPARISONS YOU HAVE TO
LIKE LITERALLY YOU KNOW HAND
ENTER IT WHICH IS. FOR HIM TO BE
TIME CONSUMING FOR PRETTY MUCH
ANYBODY.
SO THE MACHINE READABLE FORMAT
PEAS HAS BECOME THE NORM ON THE
FEDERAL SIDE IT WAS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE OPEN
GOVERNMENT INITIATIVE AND IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THIS CONTEXT
BECAUSE OF HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
FOR STAKEHOLDERS IN THE SYSTEM
TO ACCESS THE STATE RIGHT NOW SO
BOTH OF THESE.
PIECES OF THE CERTAINLY NOT
EVERYTHING WE HAVE HOPE FOR WE
REALLY WANT TO WORK WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO MOVE THIS
LEGISLATION FORWARD.
AND MAKE SURE THAT LEAVES VIEWS
TWO PIECES CAN BECOME PART OF
OUR STATUS QUO.
THANK YOU I'M DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL [inaudible]
XENA OKAY.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
WELL THAT THE LAST OF THAT
BEFORE.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT -- NOT
ONLY OF WHAT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT.
FUNDING SHOULD BE MADE AVAILABLE.
TO ADMINISTER THIS WEBSITE.
BOB FROM STATE ASIDE --
EFFECTIVELY BE AN OBSOLETE A
RELATIVE TERM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHECK PAGE EIGHTEEN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION WE DON'T GET HOME
FROM A POSITION ON THE BILL --
BUT WE THINK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
EFFORTS TO BRING TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR SYSTEM
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH HER GOING FOR THANK YOU.
OKAY.
I DO WE HAVE ANY.
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROW
RICKROLLING TRIPS IN ARCA SO SHE
SHOULD OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES.
I THANK YOU CAN COME YOU CAN GO
AHEAD COME UP HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE ONCE AGAIN RICK ROLLINS REPS
ANY ARCA SO SHE XIN REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES WE HAVE A
CONCERNS POSITION ON THIS BILL
ARCA STRONGLY SUPPORTS A
REASONABLE AND THOUGHTFUL AND
WORKABLE.
OF IDEAS AND LEGISLATION ON
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
OF ONE OF OUR SYSTEM -- WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THE THE MOVEMENT.
ON TO THE SECTIONS OF THE BILL
AND LOOK FORWARD IF THIS BILLS
APPROVED BY A COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC -- THE WOULD LIKE.
TO EXPRESS THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL [inaudible]
NIELSEN OKAY.
UP DO WE HAVE ANY MAKE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
THUNDERSTORMS COULD JUST A
COMMENT AS WANT TO THANK --
CENTER GROW FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD APPRECIATE THE WITNESS
COMING IN -- ARTICULATING --
YOUR EXPERIENCE WITH YOUR YOUR
ATTORNEYS TO TRY TO GET
INFORMATION WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
VERY DIFFICULT HOPEFULLY THIS IS
GONNA HEALTHCARE.
SUMMIT TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ISSUES AND SO I'D
LIKE -- TO THE BILL ON ALSO LIKE
REQUESTED TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
A SENATOR BELDEN CENTER WIENER.
I THINK THE TRANSPARENCY
IMPORTANT I HOPE THAT --
REGIONAL CENTERS.
CAN WORK WITH CENTER GROVE ON
TRANSPARENCY -- I SUPPORT.
THE BILL I'M GONNA VOTE FOR
TODAY -- I A WANT TO EXPRESS THE
CONCERN ABOUT.
THE ISSUE OF THE PROCESS FOR
TRANSPARENCY AND THE PROCESS HAS
TO BE.
FAIR FOR A SINGLE MOTHER WITH
THREE OR FOUR KIDS.
THAT'S THAT CAN'T SPEAKS SPEAK --
ENGLISH AND WHAT IT HAS -- DOWN
SYNDROME KID. TO GET FAIR
TREATMENT EQUAL TO AN ATTORNEY
FROM STANFORD.
AND PALO ALTO SO I THINK THE THE
WHOLE PROCESS.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
HAS TO BE OF EQUAL? FOR BOTH
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF TIMES IN THE
GRAMS IN ESPECIALLY IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM. FOR KIDS THAT
HAVE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
IT'S THE SQUEAKY WHEEL GETS THE
THE GREECE IF YOU WANT TO SET
THAT WAY AND I THINK -- I DON'T
KNOW HOW THE THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WILL APPROACH THIS
BILL BUT TRANSPARENCY IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE BUT IT HAS TO
BE TRANSPARENT FOR EVERYONE.
IN ALL FAMILIES.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF KIDS THAT
ARE OUT THERE -- THAT HAVE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
BECAUSE THE FAMILIES ARE AFRAID --
TO AFRAID -- TO HAVE THEIR KIDS
SIGNED UP -- FOR THE REGIONAL
CENTER PROGRAMS AND BE ELIGIBLE
FOR REGIONAL CENTER PROGRAMS.
OF BECAUSE OF VARIOUS
IMMIGRATION STATUS OF THE MONEY
I ONE FAMILY MEMBER.
THAT HAS THE WRONG IMMIGRATION
STATUS SO WE HAVE TO WE HAVE.
TO AND A LOT OF TIMES OF THE
KIDS THAT DON'T GET FAIR SERVICE
OKAY.
AND I KNOW THIS IS TRUE -- SO I
WANT TO EXPRESS THAT IS
SOMETHING.
THAT.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
AFTER OF THAT ASPECT OF?
TRANSPARENCY COVERED IN THE BILL.
AND I'LL JUST SAY THIS -- CENTER
GROVE IN AND I HAVE WORKED LONG
AND HARD.
FOR PROGRAMS FOR DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES IN THE ASSEMBLY
WHEN I WAS A COLLEAGUE.
AND SO I SUPPORT THE BILL BUT
BUT I THINK WE HAVE.
TO WE HAVE TO WORK ON THIS
EQUITY.
FAIRNESS -- FOR ALL RIGHT FOR
ALL FAMILIES WE HAVE TO REALIZE
THAT OTHERS WAS A THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY KIDS THAT -- I HAVE --
ELIGIBILITY IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES PROGRAM TO
CALIFORNIA THREE ON THREE
THOUSAND THERE ARE PROBABLY.
THOUSANDS MORE.
THAT HAVE ELIGIBILITY THAT JUST
TALENT.
GOT THE SERVICES.
SO THAT'S GOING TO THAT'S AN
ISSUE I THINK WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND THE
REGIONAL CENTERS AND I WANT TO
REGIONAL SERVICETO THINK ABOUT
THIS OF WAYS WE CAN.
SOLVE THIS DILEMMA AS WELL SO --
AND AS EVERYBODY KNOWS I AM --
MY DADDY TO ASSEMBLY AS DEVELOP
A DISABLED.
SO I'M AWARE HOW IT WORKS.
IF YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS MEMBERS [inaudible]
OKAY.
SENATOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH OUR TEAM ON THIS
BILL AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND I DO APPRECIATE AND AND THE
ESPECIALLY ARE BECAUSE
OPPOSITION -- NOT OPPOSITION
KIND IN BETWEEN THERE HAS TO BE
SOME KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
AND I'M TRANSPARENCY ON THE
WEBSITES IS AVAILABLE AND TO
SENATOR BILLS COME IT'S I THINK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SUPPORTING THE
BILL.
BUT THAT I THINK THE BILL
ADDRESSES THE EXACT -- TENET
THAT I BROUGHT FOR THE THE FOR
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT CAME TO
TESTIFY HE'S A LAWYER IN SHE'S A
RESEARCHER AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY AND SHE HAD TROUBLES.
SEEKING THE INFORMATION THAT SHE
NEEDED SO I'M NOT QUESTION
ANYBODY'S INTELLECTUAL AND
CAPACITY BUT IF SHE HAD TROUBLE
I WOULD HAVE TROUBLE AND EIGHTY
OF US WOULD PROBABLY HAVE
TROUBLE FINDING THE INFORMATION
THAT WE NEED ON A WEBSITE.
AM I UNDERSTAND THAT THE THE
ISSUE WITH OUR CAN WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE WORK WITH HIM
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO
FOR A UNIFORMED WEBSITE JUST
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE BUT WE NEED.
INFORMATION IN A STANDARD PLACE
SO THAT EVERYBODY CAN GO -- I
CLICKED TAB EIGHT WHENEVER I GO
HERE TO LOOK FOR THIS
INFORMATION SO -- I DO -- I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THEM ON
AND I APPRECIATE -- A AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION TO DO PASSED
TO SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE --
THIS CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO I HER TITLE AYE STONE
AYE STONE AYE BELL.
BILL I JACKSON JACKSON AYE PAN.
PAN AYE WINNER.
WIENER HI AT SIX SIX SO THAT'S
SIX ZERO AND THE BILL IS OUT.
OKAY YES IT YOUR MEDIA THE LAST
MONTH.
YEAH OKAY JUST.
OKAY YES -- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
ARE ARE WONDERFUL CHAIR IS NOT
FEELING WELL.
AND SO -- IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKELY HER HER
BILL -- SP FOUR NINETY AND I'M
GONNA CHAIR THE REMAINDER OF THE
MEETING -- IF THAT'S OKAY.
SO -- SENATOR TOTAL IF I TO COME
UP.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO HEAR A SB
FOUR NINETY BUT BEFORE WE DO
THAT WHEN WE HAVE A MOTION TO
MOVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOVE BY SENATOR BILL KALRA
PLEASE.
RICARDO I'M RETIRED OF ICE DOWN
HI STONE AYE BELL.
BELL I JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN [inaudible]
WIENER.
HI THIS US. FOR FOUR ZERO THAT'S
FOUR ZERO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NOW WE HEAR FROM SENATOR
CARL SP FOUR NINETY CAL FIRST
BENEFIT OPERATIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES -- I'D
LIKE TO START OFF BY SIFTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS LISTED
IN THE ANALYSIS -- SP FOUR NINE
ZERO WILL HELP PREVENT HUNGER
AMONG LOW INCOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELDERLY OR DISABLED AND IN
RECEIPT OF SUPPLEMENTAL.
SIX A SOCIAL SECURITY INCOME.
BY REQUIRING THE COUNTY TO
ABSTAIN FROM COLLECTING AND OVER
ISSUED CAL FIRST BENEFITS FROM.
THEM IF THE OVER INSURANCE WAS
CAUSED BY COUNTY ERROR.
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUTRITION
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM KNOWN AS
CONFESSION.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT ANTI HUNGER
PROGRAM IN THE COUNTRY.
THAT HELPS LOW INCOME -- PEOPLE
WHO ARE ELDERLY OR DISABLED WITH
THE FOOD BASKET TO HELP THEM
MEET THEIR BASIC FOOD NEEDS.
AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR
EXAMPLE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
ARE AIDED BY SNAP IN ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR COVERAGE BENEFITS
WITH OVER TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE PER MONTH.
HAVE YOU BEEN HELPED BY A FOOD
BANK FOR FOOD DISTRIBUTIONS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT AS
BEFORE NINETY IS ALSO IN LINE
WITH RECENT FEDERAL CHANGES.
CHANGES WHICH ALIGN THE
CALIFORNIA.
HEALTH REST ELIGIBILITY A TRASH
HOLD WITH FEDERAL SNAP
ELIGIBILITY THRESHOLDS WITHOUT
AS BEFORE NINETY CALIFORNIANS
WITH PRECARIOUS HEALTH NEEDS ARE
LIKELY TO GO HUNGRY.
MORE FREQUENTLY UNTIL THEY'RE
OVER PAYMENT AS RESOLVED SO ASKS
YOU MEMBERS TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
A TODAY I HAVE WITH ME JUST OF A
VERY AND AS A SIDE RECIPIENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE DISABILITY
ORGANIZING GROUP FOR INITIATING
TOTAL EQUITY.
AND JESSICA BARTH FLOW WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE IS
ONE ZERO BOTH THE AUTHOR SUPPORT
ON BOTH SIDES CENTER DEVOTED
MOTHER BUT WE ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN WHAT YOU HAVE TO
SAY WE WELCOME YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE -- NOW
THE SECRETARY FOR DESPAIRING
THAT GROUP FOR ANYTHING SO
EQUALITY -- ALSO THE VICE HERE
FOR RESOURCE RING A FAMILY
SACRAMENTO AND YOLO COUNTIES.
YEAH AND HOW WORK FEW OTHER HALF
SO -- THE MAIN THING I WOULD SAY
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING I
WILL SAY WHETHER SMALL
COLLECTION.
I HAVE SOME CRITICS OF THE BILL
OBVIOUSLY I WON'T GET TERRIBLY
INCIDENT THERE ARE OTHER HERE
I'LL TALK THEM -- AT THAT AT THE
COMING PERIOD [inaudible]
HOWEVER -- I THINK THAT THIS IS
A A VERY POSITIVE THING FOR
PERSONS -- YOU KNOW ON SSI FOR
MANY REASONS OBVIOUSLY I THINK
THAT WE GOT A BIG WIN FOR HAVING
THE FOOD STAMPS -- PROVIDED TO
US AND APPRECIATE -- EVERY
EVERYONE HERE WHO HELPED TO
ESTABLISH THAT -- LEGISLATION.
WHAT I WOULD SAY -- JUST AS A AS
A AS A PERSONAL TYPE OF
TESTIMONY.
IS THAT I'VE BEEN ON SO SECURITY
MY WHOLE LIFE I'M CURRENTLY A
DOCTOR STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO
STATE.
AND THE ALSO A SINGLE FATHER TO
AND SO -- BEING ABLE TO HAVE
THESE FOOD STAMPS ESPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THE CURRENT CUTS
THROUGH THE SO SECURITY GRANTS --
IS VERY IMPORTANT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE ENOUGH
NUTRITION IF YOU WILL WHICH HAS
LONG BEEN A POINT OF CONTENTION
FOR PERSONS WITH -- FROM MY
COMMUNITY SO -- IF THERE'S ANY
WAY THAT WE COULD -- FORMALLY AN
ARGUMENT TO NOT JUST PURSUE THIS
BILL BUT ALSO PERFECTED IF YOU
WILL AND MAKE IT A IN A WAY THIS
SERVICE PERSONS ON A SOCIETY I
THINK WITHIN THE ESSENCE IS
MEANT TO I THINK -- AMONG IN
SUPPORT OF THANK YOU JOSEPH IS
VERY YES THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO
REALLY APPRECIATE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST ABOUT THE
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
OF HEALTH WE GET CALLS
FREQUENTLY PEOPLE KNOW THEY SEE
ME HERE THE CAPITAL MIGHT ALSO
KNOW THAT WE SERVE AS A SUPPORT
CENTER FOR LEGAL SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND I PERSONALLY MANAGED A
QUESTIONS THAT COME IN THROUGH A
STATEWIDE LIST SERVE -- AND WE
REGULARLY GET QUESTIONS THE
QUESTION THAT WE FREQUENTLY GET
ON THIS ISSUE IS IS THERE REALLY
NO WAY TO PREVENT SOMEBODY WHO'S
ELDERLY OR DISABLED FROM HAVING
TO GIVE FOOD STAMPS.
BACK TO THE STATE -- WHEN WE
ALREADY KNOW THE BENEFITS ARE
ARE SO LITTLE AND THEY'LL GO
HUNGRY AND THE ANSWER TO THAT SO
FAR IS NOW -- SO THIS BILL WILL
HELP US MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION
SO THAT SOMEBODY CAN KEEP THE
BENEFITS THAT ARE MEANT FOR THEM --
TO PREVENT HUNGER THAT MONTH AND
FOR THIS FOR VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THE BILL AND JR I DON'T THINK
THANK YOU FOR TO SO MANY OF
THOSE -- ARE IN FAVOR IF YOU
PLEASE STEP UP TO THE MIKE AND
PLEASE TELL US WHO YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER NUMBERS I
UNDERSTAND CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
FOR US TO SIGN STRONG SUPPORT
AND THINK THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
AND MANY MEMBERS CHAIR CALL
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
AS THE COALITION CALIFORNIA
OPERATES ORGANIZES A STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IF NOT A HOLD OF ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION AS BEFORE NINETY
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THING THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE DAY AS WE HAVE A MOTION --
BY SENATOR.
BILL A CENTER CAUGHT ALWAYS WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS --
VERY IMPORTANT BILL FORWARD I
WOULD LOVE TO PARTNER WITH YOUR
VEHICLE WATER IF I MAY -- AND I
WISH YOU GODSPEED ELECT YOU HAVE
A CLOSING REMARK.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE VOTE.
OKAY THIS IS -- DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE CALL THE ROLL --
THE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU.
CA.GOV.
HER TITLE I STONE BY STONE HI
BILL.
BILL I JACKSON.
PAN.
WIENER.
IT'S GOT THREE THREE WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN FOR YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WIENER WAS HERE BEFORE.
OKAY WE'RE JUST LOOKING AT MY
BILL ABOUT A MONTH [inaudible]
OKAY.
TAKE OVER THE NO [inaudible]
THE RUBIO.
SB [inaudible]
SIX ONE FOUR WELCOME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WELCOME TO WITNESS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT.
MAYBE CAN.
WHAT YES THEY?
TODAY I AM PROUD TO INTRODUCE SB
SIX ONE FOR A BILL THAT WOULD
EXTEND THE INCLUSIVE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION HE SEAGRAM
PROGRAM THE GRANT PROPOSAL MUST
DEMONSTRATE HOW COUNTIES WILL
INCREASE ACCESS.
SUBSIDIZE INCLUSIVE EASY
PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN UP TO FIVE
YEARS OLD PARTICULARLY THOSE
WITH EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS AND LOW
INCOME OR HIGH NEEDS COMMUNITIES.
RESEARCH SHOWS EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMS CAN IMPROVE
CHILD'S.
DEVELOPMENTAL PROGRESS AND
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES ESPECIALLY
FOR STUDENTS WITH EXCEPTIONAL
NEEDS THESE PROGRAMS CREATE A
SENSE OF BELONGING.
PROMOTE POSITIVE SOCIAL
RELATIONSHIPS.
AND HELP CHILDREN PARTICIPATE.
PARTICIPATING TO DEVELOP
IMPORTANT SKILLS.
ARE OUT TODAY WITH ME MADAM.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
PAMELA GUESS WHAT THE LA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THAT WILL
TESTIFY ON MY BEHALF THANK YOU.
MISS NASH AFTER HER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR --
THE PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY.
AGAIN FOR THE RECORD PAMELA
GIVES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
I WOULD FIRST LIKE TO THANK THE
SENATOR HAD THOUGHT.
THE SENATOR FOR OFFERING SB.
SIX FOURTEEN THIS LEGISLATION IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE DESPITE THE
CONSISTENT EFFORTS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS MADE OVER SEVERAL
YEARS WE STILL SEE GAPS IN
ACCESS TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
ESPECIALLY REGARDING STUDENTS
WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
SB SIX FOURTEEN WOULD MAKE THE
CURRENT GRANT PROGRAM ON GOING
AND WOULD REQUIRE PROGRAM DATA
AND EVALUATIONS BUY THIS CD.
A CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN ORDER TO INFORM
THESE EFFORTS GOING FORWARD.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SERVES OVER
TEN THOUSAND CHILDREN IN OUR
EARLY HEAD START -- STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS -- THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE COUNTY IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN YEAR --
WE HAD ONE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS THAT
WE SERVED.
AND THAT WAS IN OUR HEAD START
EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY ONE CHILDREN AGES
BIRTH THROUGH THREE YEARS OLD
WERE SERVED AND WHO HAD SPECIAL
NEEDS IN OUR EARLY HEAD START
PROGRAM.
SB SIX FOURTEEN WILL CODIFY THE
INCLUSIVE EARLY LEARNING EARLY
CARE PILOT PROGRAM AND CREATED
THIS YEAR OR CREATED LAST YEAR
IN AB EIGHTEEN OH EIGHT ISSUE
ALL AND REMEMBER AND THAT WAS
THROUGH THE TRAILER BILL.
THERE WAS ONE TIME FUNDING SO
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE THESE EFFORTS.
IN THE IN THE FUTURE -- AND THEN --
AND BE ABLE TO PROVIDE LOCAL
FLEXIBILITY TO SOME OF THOSE
ELEAZAR RECEIVING FUNDING AT THE
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
ALSO W FEEL LIKE -- THE
FLEXIBILITY IT FROM SB SIX
FOURTEEN WOULD PROVIDE AS THE
ELLIE AIDS WITHIN OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE LOCAL NEEDS
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE THOSE FOLKS
REALLY KNOW.
THEIR AREAS SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT ON
SB SIX FOURTEEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY --
THIS -- BILL ENJOYS SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE IF --
THERE ANY OTHERS THAT LIKE TO
SUPPORT SB SIX ONE FOUR PLEASE
COME FORWARD -- KERRISON WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THREE YEAR ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
IF NOT IS THERE ANYONE OPPOSED
SB SIX ONE FOUR PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
CENTER LOVELL MOVES A BILL --
CENTER RUBIO WHICH I CAN MAKE A
CLOSING COMMENT.
THANK YOU.
WELL AS A FORMER EDUCATOR I CAN
TELL YOU WITH PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE HOW IMPORTANT THIS
SAYS.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I WILL GO AHEAD AND NOT KALRA
THIS IS DUE PASS -- WITH
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
APPROPRIATIONS. FOR TITLE STONE.
STONE I DON'T.
THE BILL I JACKSON PAN WIENER.
HAS TO BUT WE HAVE TO LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN.
IN CASE THANK YOU.
PRESENT FROM PRESENTATION.
US SENATOR PORTANTINO.
SB.
SIX NINETY FIVE NO [inaudible]
ONE SIXTY SIX THANK YOU.
WE HAVE TO TODAY SB ONE SIXTY
THREE WELCOME SENATOR.
I GOT ONE OF MY BILL NUMBERS
WRONG THE LAST COMMITTEE SO.
THAT WAS MY COULDN'T SEE IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS -- SP -- ONE SIXTY
THREE ELIMINATE SIGNIFICANT
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS IMPOSED BY
HEALTH PLANS THAT ARE PREVENTING
FAMILIES FROM ACCESSING --
BEHAVIOR HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH AUTISM AND OF
THE VICE CHAIR AND I HAD A
ROBUST CONVERSATION ON THIS BILL.
IN THE LAST COMMITTEE -- SP ONE
SIXTY THREE ALLOWS CALIFORNIA'S
WITH AUTISM TO RECEIVE COVERAGE
FOR TREATMENT PRESCRIBED BY
THEIR PHYSICIAN.
OR PSYCHOLOGIST TO KNOW THEM
BEST NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
TREATMENT THAT MAY NOT FIT THEIR
PARTICULAR NEEDS.
THE BILL ADDRESSES ROADBLOCKS TO
COVERAGE FOR PARENTS WHO FOR
WORK REASONS ARE FOR FAMILY
PRESSURES CANNOT FULLY
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR CHILD'S
THERAPY SESSION.
OR WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE TO
RECEIVE SERVICES AT ARE NOT A
SCHOOL OR DAYCARE SETTING.
THIS BILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
ACROSS THE STATE -- WE HAVE
RECEIVED OVER TWO HUNDRED
LETTERS FROM PARENTS AND SUPPORT
AS WELL AS FROM NUMEROUS AUTISM
ORGANIZATIONS AND PROFESSIONALS --
TO MAKE TODAY I HAVE JIM LANDRY
ON THE D. I. R. FOR TIME
COALITION TO PRESENT TESTIMONY
ON ITS BEHALF MISTER ANDREW.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THIS IS A TWENTY YEAR STRUGGLE --
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY NINE WHEN
WE THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY ACT HADN'T
SAID THAT AUTISM SHOULD BE
TREATED THE SAME AS PHYSICAL
AILMENTS -- THE STRUGGLE HAS
BEEN FROM BOTH THE REGULATORS
SIDE AND THE LEGISLATIVE SIDE TO
TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT.
CHILDREN AS WELL AS ADULTSIN
THE STATE RECEIVE TREATMENT OF
FOR AUTISM COVERED BY THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANIES INSURANCE
COVERAGE THAT THEY PAID -- FOR
IN THE SAME MANNER THAT THEY
RECEIVE COVERAGE FOR PHYSICAL
AILMENTS -- WE'VE PASSED
NUMEROUS LAWS WITH CUSTOMERS Là
REGULATIONS AND NUMEROUS
LAWSUITS -- UNFORTUNATELY -- THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES -- THE
HEALTH PLANS HAVE BEEN KICKING
AND DRAGGING THEIR FEET AND NOW
WE FIND OURSELVES TO THE POINT
WHERE HOPEFULLY WE CAN FINALLY
PUT THAT TO REST AND CHILDREN
AND ADULTS CAN GET THE HELP THAT
THEY NEED.
WRITER JURAI VOTE THANK YOU.
GIVE YOUR TESTIMONY ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
SIXTY THREE PLEASE COME FORWARD.
CNN IS ANYONE OPPOSED SB ONE
WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM TABLE.
BECAUSE IT IN THE MIDDLE
ACTUALLY IT LOOKS.
PREFERRED LEAVE HE TABLE SPOTS
FOR THOSE AN ACTUAL OPPOSITION.
AT DANIEL'S AVEENO ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES OUR
POSITION IS CONCERNS AT THIS
POINT.
AND OUR CONCERN IS QUITE SIMPLY
BASED IN THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING THAT WHATEVER SKILLS
ARE LEARNED.
IN THESE SETTINGS CAN BE
GENERALIZED TO THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY.
AND IF PARENTS CAN PARTICIPATE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT'S A CHALLENGE
SO WE'D LOVE TO SEE A WAY IN
WHICH SHOWS THE SERVICE
PROVIDERS CAN COME UP WITH AN
ALTERNATIVE WAY FOR THESE.
LESSONS WE BROUGHT OUT OF THIS
CLINICAL SETTING A WE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHORED
SPONSORS ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY.
PLEASE.
TO FOR I THANK YOU AYE MICHELLE
HI ADAM A BOARD CERTIFIED
BEHAVIOR ANALYSTS REPRESENTING
THAT CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM FOR
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS I'M
SORRY THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
FOR APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS.
OR CURRENTLY SERVE AS A VICE
CHAIR PUBLIC POLICY.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS COMMITMENT TO
ENSURING ACCESS TO QUALITY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH AUTISM AND
OTHER DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S VERY
NEAR AND DEAR TO MY HEART.
HOWEVER UNFORTUNATELY HASN'T
OPPOSE POSITION BUT WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC WE CAN ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS WITH CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE LANGUAGE ALREADY
INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
OUR CONCERNS ARE THAT CURRENT
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN SB ONE
SIXTY THREE HAS NEGATIVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
AS WRITTEN THE BILL
SIGNIFICANTLY ALTERS THE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
PRACTITIONER SERVING A
VULNERABLE POPULATION.
WITHOUT SUFFICIENT MINIMUM
STANDARDS TO PRACTICE
COMPETENTLY.
CONSUMERS WILL BE AT INCREASING
RISK OF ROSEN OF QUALITY OF
SERVICE.
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THE BILL
WOULD PLACE IN STATUTE AN
ALTERNATE SET OF STANDARDS FOR
ABA PROFESSIONALS.
THAT DO NOT ALIGN WITH THE
QUALIFICATIONS REQUIRED FOR A BE
A CERTIFICATION BY THE BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS CERTIFICATION BOARD.
WHICH IS SPECIFICALLY REFERENCED
IN THE MANDATE AND IS THE ONLY
ACCREDITED CERTIFICATION THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS FOR THE
PROVIDER LEVEL.
HELLO I WAS CONCERNED THAT THIS
WILL CREATE CONFUSION IN THE
MARKETPLACE BY MIXING
REQUIREMENTS FOR OTHER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS.
WE BELIEVE THIS HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO DISRUPT THE
PROFESSIONAL PROVIDER PIPELINE
WHICH WOULD CREATE SERIOUS
ACCESS ISSUES.
HOWEVER HAS REQUESTED CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH LANGUAGE ALREADY INCLUDED
IN THE BILL RE REQUEST
CLARIFICATION ON THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR QUALIFIED
AUTISM SERVICE PROVIDERS.
THIS SPECIFICALLY PROVIDE
APPLIED BEHAVIOR ANALYSIS
SERVICES FROM OTHER QUALIFIED
AUTISM SERVICE PROVIDERS.
WHO PROVIDE OTHER EVIDENCE BASED
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTIONS LAST
YEAR AMENDMENTS WERE ACCEPTED
WHICH SEPARATE THE REQUIREMENTS
FOR A BE A PARA PROFESSIONALS?
FROM NINE A. B. A. PARA
PROFESSIONALS AND CALIBER HAS
OFFERED LANGUAGE CONSISTENT WITH
THIS REQUEST THAT DOES NOT
INTERFERE WITH THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT OF THE BILL BUT SIMPLY
CLARIFIES THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
THEY ARE SEEKING.
DO NOT APPLY TO ABA PROVIDERS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
THAT LEAD TO AMENDMENTS.
AND WHICH WILL ENSURE ACCESS TO
QUALITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS
THOUGHT TO THE OTHER DEVELOPING
OF DISABILITIES THEY GIVE JUST
MONEY.
NEXT PLEASE A GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
JENNIFER ALI WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS -- AND
AT WE APPRECIATE THE TIME TO
DISCUSS THIS BILL AGAIN WITHOUT
MOST OF YOU CAN I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT -- CAPS MEMBER
HEALTH PLANS CURRENTLY PROVIDE.
MEDICAL IMPLIED BEHAVIOR
ANALYSIS SERVICES TO THEIR
ENROLLEES WITH AUTISM -- SB NINE
FORTY SIX IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
MOVED AUTISM COVERAGE FROM THE
REGIONAL CENTERS TO HEALTH PLAN
COVERAGE.
AND WE ALSO HAVE REQUIREMENTS
THAT -- BUYER REGULATORS TO
REQUIRE THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
NETWORKS FOR ORAL LEASE TO
ACCESS CARE -- AND SINCE THAT
TIME -- AUTISM SERVICES HAVE
BEEN A PART -- INCLUDED AS AN
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFIT -- SO
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED BY CALLIE
PA THIS BILL DOES IN OUR OPINION
WATER DOWN THE TREATMENT
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROVIDERS FOR
THIS FAIRY I. NEEDY POPULATION
OF THAT -- CAUSES SOME CONCERNS
FOR US -- YOU KNOW GENERALLY
SPEAKING HEALTH PLANS RELY ON
LICENSED -- PROVIDERS TO PROVIDE
CARE TO THEIR ENROLLEES IN THIS
IS A DISEASE GROUP THAT DOESN'T
HAVE SPECIFIC LICENSING CATEGORY --
TO PROVIDE TREATMENT -- SO IT'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT WE HAVE
PROVIDERS ARE CERTIFIED BY PORTS
BUT NOT NECESSARILY LICENSED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO IT'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT WATERING
DOWN THE PROVIDER REQUIREMENTS
ON THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS IN
STATUTE THAT WOULD INTO PLACE
LAST YEAR THAT CAUSES SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS FOR MY MEMBERS --
AND I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF
CLEAR -- FIVE YOU KNOW IN
CLOSING YOU KNOW -- THERE ARE A
LOT OF BILLS THAT CHANGE HOW
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE -- IS IS
COVERED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS YEAR AND SO AS
WE LOOK AT CHANGING REQUIREMENTS
AND WHAT HEALTH PLANS COVERAGE
WE DO HAVE.
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THOSE
CHANGES IN THE ADDED COST OUR
MEMBERS THANK YOU WILL ALLOW FOR
ONE MORE COMPREHENSIVE
OPPOSITION AND THE REST WILL BE
JUST NAME AND WHETHER YOU'RE
SUPPORTER OPPOSE THE BILL.
SEVENTY WALKEN'S ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES WITH ECHO THAT
PREVIOUS COMMENTS AND ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
KAREN SARKISIAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
RIPOSTE THANK YOU.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS WITH A CO
CAPTAIN ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
NOW WILL COME BACK [inaudible]
TO TWO SENATORS.
THE BILL BILLS WHEN MOVED --
SENATOR PORTANTINO WE HAD OUR
DISCUSSIONS ON THE BILL I
SUPPORT THE BILL WHICH I CAN
MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT.
YES THANK YOU -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND I
THINK SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT.
ARE POINTED TO THE BILL'S
DEFICIENCIES ARE ACTUALLY WHAT
MAKES THE BILL STRONG AS IT
ALLOWS.
DOCTORS TO PROVIDE.
PROVIDE A PRESCRIBED ALTERNATIVE
CARE TO THE CURRENT DOG MY AND
CHILDREN RESPONSE SOME CHILDREN
RESPOND TO THAT AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR HIS FATHER GRANDFATHER OF A
SEVERELY AUTISTIC GRANDDAUGHTER
WHO I LOVE TO PIECES -- I'VE.
I BABBLE YES IN HER HONOR AND
THIS IS DUE PASSED -- TO
CORPORATIONS.
RICARDO STONE.
STONE HI BEL BEL AYE JACKSON PAN
WIENER. TWO OKAY LISTEN. TO WITH
BELIEVE THE ROLL OPEN SENATOR
AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO SP.
ONE SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU EVER
SO CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF --
IN PARTICULAR TERENCE SMITH.
FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF SO
DILIGENTLY -- SB ONE SEVENTY TWO
HAS MULTIPLE MOVING FACTORS
WITHIN THE BILL ALL RELATING TO
ENSURING FIREARMS ARE PROPERLY
LOCKED AND STORED.
SECTION ONE OF SB ONE SEVEN TWO
AN AXE WE KEEP OUR SENIOR SAY
FACT AND WE'RE REQUIRE REGULATE
REGULATIONS AND PROCEDURES FOR
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITIONS.
WITH THE IN A RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITY WHEN THE FACILITY
ALLOWS RESIDENTS TO HAVE GUNS
AND AMMUNITION.
THE BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
FACILITIES TO ACCEPT AMMUNITION
OR FIREARMS BUT IF THEY CHOOSE
TO ALLOW THIS WE WANT PROCEDURES
IN PLACE TO PROTECT RESIDENTS
AND STAFF.
THIS IS A VULNERABLE POPULATION
AND AS SUCH WE WANT TO HAVE
THESE LAYERS OF PROTECTION IN.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND STAKEHOLDERS TO CREATE A
SYSTEM.
THAT PROTECTS THE RESIDENTS
STAFF AND VISITORS FOR ENSURING
ULTIMATE SAFETY YOU MA'AM AND
SIMPLIFY THE INSPECTION PROCESS
FOR WEAPONS.
IN THESE FACILITIES WE HAVE
AGREED TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH
THE SPONSORED THE DEPARTMENT IN
THE COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP A
TRANSPARENCY POLICY.
APPLE PROVIDE NOTICE TO
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHEN THERE ARE FIREARMS PRESENT
PERMITTED IN ONE OF THESE
FACILITIES.
I HAVE WITH ME MONICA MILLER ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER ADVOCATES
FOR OUR CFE REFORM AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MILLER PLEASE MISTER CHAIR OF
THE MEMBERS MONICA MILLER
REPRESENTING THE CONSUMER
ADVOCATES FOR RC AT THE REFORM.
AN RC AT THE IS A RESIDENTIAL
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY AND FIRST
AND FOREMOST I WANT TO THANK
YOUR STAFF WHO GAVE US MORE TIME
THAN SHE PROBABLY SHOULD HAVE.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
VERY MUCH SHE WAS VERY GENEROUS
TO ASK -- ALSO WORKING THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES.
SO OUR OUR PIECE OF THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS RELATED TO ON THESE
FACILITIES THESE WERE CREATED
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE THEY ARE
NOT MEDICAL FACILITIES.
WHAT THEY ARE IS YOU HAVE TO
PLACE MOM DAD GRANDMA GRANDPA?
INTO A FACILITY THAT AND HAVE A
LOT OF HEALTH ISSUES BUT THEY'RE
STARTING TO FEEL A LITTLE BIT SO
YOU WANT TO HAVE.
SOME SORT OF CARRY SIX BEDS FOR
EXAMPLE BUT SOME SORT OF CARE
FOR THEM. FOR THE MEN TO BE VERY
MUCH LIKE THEIR OWN HOMES TO
WHATEVER THEY WANT TO BRING WITH
THEM.
AS LONG AS THE FACILITY ALLOWS
IT THEY CAN BRING UP WITH THEM.
SO -- SOMETIMES FIREARMS TO COME
AND SOMETIMES.
YOU KNOW AMMUNITION COMES IN AND
THERE'S NO WAY FOR DSS
COMMUNICATOR LICENSING IVISION
AT THIS POINT TO KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT THIS FIREARMS EXIST.
AND AGAIN WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT
YES YOU CAN HAVE THEM NO YOU
CAN'T WE'RE JUST SAYING THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A MECHANISM.
AND WHICH TO ENSURE SAFETY FOR
THE CARE GIVERS CHILDREN ARE
COMING AND FAMILY MEMBERS ARE
VISITING XRS THAT'S ALL THE BILL
SIMPLY DOES COMMERCIAL
PERSPECTIVE AND AGAIN WE DO HAVE
SOME MORE WORK TO DO ON IT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO KEEP YOUR
STUFF PRIZED.
AS WE MOVE THIS BILL TO THE
PROCESS ON AS WELL AS WORK WITH
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES TO
MAKE SURE THEY CAN ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT THE LEGISLATION FOR
THE END OF THE DAY IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T WORK IT DOESN'T WORK.
OUT AND I THINK YOU ORIGINALLY
THOUGHT THANKS FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF SB ONE SEVENTY TWO PLEASE
COME FORWARD [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
HELLO.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSHUA BLOCK ON
BEHALF OF MARCH FOR LIFE
CALIFORNIA MUCH REALIZE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY SUPPORTS SB
ONE SEVENTY TWO BECAUSE OF ITS
CAPACITY.
REDUCE GUN VIOLENCE AND SUICIDE
BY FIREARMS THIS BILL ENCOURAGES
RESPONSIBLE GUN STORAGE AND
SENIOR CENTERS WHICH IS.
IMPORTANT ASPECT TO COMBAT IN.
THE GUN VIOLENCE EPIDEMIC.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ENERGY TO SUPPORT IT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE SEVENTY TWO IF NOT IS THERE
ANYBODY OPPOSED SB ONE SEVENTY
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WELCOME TO TAKE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
SORRY. TWO SMALL TABLE.
THE TWO SMALL GUYS YEAH WELL YOU
KNOW.
SOMETHING GOOD MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SAMPRAS REPRESENTING
DOLLARS CALIFORNIA -- IN IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
NOT BECAUSE WE WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THAT -- PROTECTION SHOULD
BE IN PLACE AS A MATTER OF FACT
IN TALKING WITH OUR ATTORNEYS
AND ACTUALLY TALKING TO SOME
FACILITIES.
UP FACILITIES THEMSELVES HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
PRIVATE CONTRACT A PRIVATE SET
OF RULES AND REGULATIONS AS TO
WHAT IS ACCEPTED AND WHAT IS NOT
AND HOW TO HANDLE ALL OF THESE
ISSUES.
ALLTHE TRANSFER ALL OF THE
REMOVAL ALL OUR STUFF IS ALREADY
COVERED BY LAW.
HOW THAT ALL HAPPENS BUT A
FACILITY CAN ACTUALLY HAS -- AS
A AS A CONDITION OF BEING A
RESIDENT THERE HOW DO I KNOW.
MY FATHER IN LAW CENTER HR
RICHARDSON IS A RESIDENT OF ONE
OF THESE FACILITIES HE IS THE
ARGUABLY THE GODFATHER THE
SECOND MEMON STATE CALIFORNIA --
AN END YET IT'S IT'S WILL BE NOT
OKAY FOR HIM TO HAVE FARMS RIGHT
NOW.
BUT THAT'S THE SITUATION THAT'S
REGULATED WITH THE WITH THE
FACILITY AND IT'S WORKING OUT
FINE -- WE HEARD ABOUT THE
EPIDEMIC OF GUN VIOLENCE AT SOME
OF THESE FACILITIES WE ARE
UNAWARE OF THIS BEING ANY SORT
OF REAL PROBLEM.
AND WE DIDN'T SEE THAT DSS WAS
ONE WAS BRINING BRING IN THIS
ISSUE BUT OTHER FOLKS WHO WHO
WHO HAD CONCERN OVER THIS.
PHONE FOR THESE REASONS AND AND
THE FACT THAT.
A COOKIE CUTTER RESPONSE FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE.
USUALLY NEVER HELPS EVERYBODY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WERE IN
OPPOSITION.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD AND WE
WOULD NATURALLY FLOW SO STATION
ALSO HERE FOR CALIFORNIA RIFLE
AND PISTOL ASSOCIATION AS WELL.
A MALL ECHO SOME OF THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE MISTER CREDIT IS --
WE FEEL THIS ONE'S ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH IS IS AN
APPROPRIATE IT'S IF YOU.
AND WE'RE STILL DIGESTING THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED THE ANALYSIS HERE -- BUT
BASED ON THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE
IT ALMOST LOOKS LIKE IT
DISCOURAGES FROM FACILITIES FROM
TAKING AND FARMS BECAUSE OF THE
LIABILITIES.
AND THE PROCEDURE AS YOU SEE
FIREARM HAVE TO BE SEPARATED
FROM AMMUNITION WITH FIRING PENS
EXTRACTED EXCEDRIN FOR
PHOTOGRAPHS AND AND WHATNOT SO --
LIKE I SAID WE'RE STILL GONNA
DIE JUST AS AMENDMENTS BUT WE
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION WE FEEL
LIKE THIS IS JUST REALLY
DISCOURAGING PRESIDENT'S COMING
ABLE TO TO KEEP HER ARMS SIR
THANK YOU FOR JUST ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN CAPPING LUNCH
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
SHOOTING SPORTS FOUNDATION
SAFARI CLUB.
INTERNATIONAL SPORTSMEN'S
COALITION WE'RE ALL IN
OPPOSITION BASED ON SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE EARLIER AGAIN WE
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT -- WHEN
PEOPLE ALSO MOVE FROM THESE
FACILITIES THERE'S ALSO STEP
DOWN TO DIFFERENT PLACES THAT
THEY GO THIS CAN CREATE SOME A
LEGAL QUAGMIRE -- FOR THE THE
FAMILIES IT CAN ALSO BE A
PROBLEM IF UPON.
THEIR DEATH ON THE TRANSFER INTO
IN THE STATE SO WHAT KIND OF
CREATING A REAL STICKY WICKET
HERE AND OUR OPPOSITION WAS
ORIGINALLY BASED ON THE OTHER
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL I KNOW
WE'RE JUST FOCUSED ON THESE
AMENDMENTS TODAY.
BUT WE ARE A OPPOSED TO THE
DIRECTION OF THE BALL BUT I WANT
TO THANK CENTER PORTANTINO FOR
LETTING ME BORROW HIS MICROPHONE.
THANK YOU AND THE OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION SB ONE SEVENTY TO
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING.
NONE WILL COME BACK TO OUR
SENATORS.
SENATOR BILLS MOVED TO BUILD
THIS IS DUE PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS.
CENTER REJECT CLOSE JUST THE WAR
TRYING TO MAKE THESE FACILITIES
SAFE AND HAVE A LOGICAL.
WHAT WE THINK IS A LOGICAL
APPROACH AND I WAS OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM
TO COME UP WITH THE RIGHT THE?
SWEET SPOT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE OKAY.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE SB ONE
SEVENTY TWO PORTANTINO THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FURTADO STONE NO
STONE NO.
BELL.
BELL I JACKSON PAN RIGHT HAND
SIDE WIENER [inaudible] TWO ONE
TWO ONE WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN SENATOR REAR TO MOVE
ONTO YOUR SB.
SIX NINETY FIVE WE ARE THANK YOU --
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
TODAY I'M PRESENTING SB SIX
NINETY FIVE WHICH WILL
AUTHORIZES. TO MEET UP 25% OF
ITS SHARE OF REGIONAL HOUSING
NEEDS BY ADOPTING A PROGRAM.
THAT VOLUNTARY PROGRAM THAT
PROMOTES AND ASSIST IN THE
PLACEMENT OF FOSTER YOUTH.
IN EXISTING FAMILY HOUSEHOLDS
PEOPLE SAY YOU'RE NOT BUILDING
HOUSES BUT THIS BILL WERE
BUILDING HOMES AND I THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT -- SB SIX
NINETY FIVE ALLOWS A CITY TO
DEEM A HOUSING UNIT
PARTICIPATING IN A HOME SHARING
ARRANGEMENT ALSO -- HOME SHARING
ARRANGEMENT WITH AT LEAST ONE
LOW MODERATE INCOME SENIOR OR
DISABLED OCCUPANT IS A VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF MEETING ITS REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS -- SINCE THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION PROCESS DOES NOT PLAN
FOR FORTUNE POPULATIONS OF
FOSTER YOUTH IN NEED.
OF IMMEDIATE AND FUTURE HOUSING
FLEXIBILITY IS NEEDED BOTH THE
PLAN AND FOR PHIL THE STATE'S
RESPONSE RESPONSIBILITY OF FIND
QUALITY FOSTER HOMES.
OF FINDING A HOME FOR FOSTER
YOUTH IS ESSENTIAL FOR THESE
CHILDREN HAS OUTCOMES FOR THOSE
WHO AGING OUT OF FOSTER CARE
OFTEN FRANKLY GRAHAM.
COMPARED TO THOSE WHO EXIT EXIT
THE SYSTEM WITH A PERMANENT
LINKS TO A CARING ADULT OR
FAMILY COURT IN THE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA ONE THIRD
OF YOUTH WHO AGE OUT OF FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM.
SHOW EVIDENCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS THE MOST PREVALENT
DIAGNOSIS BEING P. T. S. D.
ALCOHOL OR SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
DEPRESSION.
LIKEWISE THE ALLIANCE FOR
CHILDREN'S WHITE RIGHTS FOUND
THAT HALF OF YOUNG ADULTS WHO H.
OUT OF FOSTER CARE AND UP
HOMELESS OR EVEN INCARCERATED.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR CITIES -- YOU
KNOW I HAVE THIS.
NOTION THAT ECHOES BACK TEN
YEARS WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY
THAT IF WE COULD CREATE.
NONTRADITIONAL FAMILY BONDS AND
PLACE THESE YOUNG PEOPLE IN
THOSE HOMES THOSE CONNECTIONS
CAN CARRY FORWARD AFTER.
EMANCIPATION AND THAT'S WHAT I'M
TRYING TO DO HERE TRYING TO FIND
SOME.
LOCALLY BASED INCENTIVE PROGRAM
TO JUST SEE IF WE CAN
VOLUNTARILY PLACE FOSTER YOUTH I
MEAN I KNOW MISTER BELL HAS
WORKED HIS ENTIRE.
LEGISLATIVE AND AND COUNTY
SUPERVISORIAL CAREER IN TRYING
TO HELP.
THIS VULNERABLE POPULATION AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT'S
IT'S IT'S NOT.
TAKING ON AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
IN A NEGATIVE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN A NEGATIVE WAY IT'S
NOT.
IT'S JUST A SMALL.
IN ESSENCE PILOT PROJECT TO
CREATE A LOCALLY DRIVEN
VOLUNTARY INCENTIVE.
THE PUT THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN
HOMES I KNOW IT DOESN'T BUILD A
NEW HOME.
BUT GOD THESE ARE KIDS WHO.
DESPERATELY NEED.
A PLACE TO SLEEP A PLACE TO STAY
AND A FAMILY THAT'S GONNA LOVE
THEM AND CARE FOR THEM AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT.
THANK YOU SENATOR TOM CALL UPON
THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
NINETY FIVE IF YOU CAN COME
FORWARD PLEASE.
THOSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY IN OPPOSITION SB
SIX NINETY FIVE PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
BRIAN AUGUSTA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION.
OUR ORGANIZATION ALONG WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT WESTERN CENTER --
REGRETTABLY GOVERNMENT REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE -- NOT
SURE HOW ARE OPPOSITION DIDN'T
GET REFLECTED AND PERHAPS --
THERE IS A DISCONNECT AND
SENDING A LETTER BUT OUR HAVE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND I KNOW HE'S
AWARE OF OUR CONCERNS AS WELL --
JUST WANNA REITERATE THOSE
CONCERNS HERE TODAY.
THE FIRST IS THERE'S NO QUESTION
A MISS PORTANTINO IS PASSIONATE
ABOUT -- FOSTER CARE PLACEMENTS
AND WE AGREE WITH HIM THAT WE
NEED. TO ACHIEVE BETTER OUTCOMES
THERE AND WE LOVE TO FIND A
SYSTEM THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO DO
THAT.
WE DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS THE
SYSTEM TO DO THAT I THINK NOT
ONLY DOES IT HAVE THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF REDUCING PLANNING
FOR HOUSING.
FOR LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
GENERALLY -- BY REDUCING THE
CITY'S OBLIGATION TO PLAN BY
REDUCING ARENA.
BUT IT ALSO AND SOME OF THIS IS
ALSO NOTED BY AT THE END OF THE
ANALYSIS IS JUST A LOT OF
INCONGRUENT.
ARE ELEMENTS TO THIS BILL
INCIDENTS DON'T SEEM TO BE
CORRECT WHAT IT WHAT ABOUT A
CITY PUTTING THAT PROGRAM
TOGETHER INCENTIVIZE IS A A
POTENTIAL FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT
TO TAKE ON THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
ASSEMBLY BECAUSE THE CITY WOULD
GET ARENA REDUCTION THAT'S NOT
CLEAR TO AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A FUNCTION THAT IS PRIMARILY
CARRIED OUT BY THE COUNTIES.
THAT WERE GIVING CREDIT TO THE
SET TO A CITY TO DO.
WE'RE ASKING A CD COGS IN KNOW.
LITTLE ABOUT THE SUBJECT TO MAKE
AN ASSESSMENT SO ALL OF THOSE
SEE MIKE IN THE END OF THE DAY
WON'T REALLY ACHIEVE THE
INTENDED.
IMPACT BUT IT WILL POTENTIALLY
LEAD TO A REDUCTION IN OUR
PLANNING OBLIGATIONS AND FOR
THOSE REASONS GIVEN OUR OUR
INCREDIBLE HOUSING CRISIS WE
WOULD JUST CONTINUE TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL AND HOPE THAT WE CAN
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO FIND A
SOLUTION THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE HIS GOALS.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS REMAIN
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY OTHERS
AN OPPOSITION SB.
SIX NINETY FIVE SIGNAL TAKE
ABOUT TWO OR SENATOR BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY -- I BELIEVE IF A CITY
GIVES FUNDS TO A GROUP HOME FOR
FOSTER USE.
THAT WOULD QUALIFY TO MEET THE
RANGE -- OBLIGATIONS IT SEEMS
RATHER INCONGRUOUS THAT THE
STATE.
IS ADVOCATING REDUCING.
THE AMOUNT OF FOSTER USE IN
GROUP HOMES.
AND ALLOWING THE READ A THE
REASON HOUSING ALLOCATION TO BE
COUNTED IF THEY GIVE MONEY TO A
A GROUP HOME -- BUT NOT A FAMILY
FOSTER CARE HOME.
SO I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THAT ARE WE ADOPTED A
LAW -- THANKS -- SOME WOMEN
STONE HAD IT TO DO A REFORM OF
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM TO
ENCOURAGE.
KIDS -- TO RE GET OUT OF GROUP
HOMES.
OKAY THAT WAS THAT IS NOW SET
THE STATE POLICY.
WE WANT WE WANT TO FOSTER YOU
HAVE TO GO INTO FAMILY HOMES OR
TO LIVE IN A AND TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING ONCE THEY REACHED.
ONCE THEY TURN EIGHTEEN SO
THAT'S THE THAT'S A POLICY.
SO IT SEEMS LIKE A VERY STRANGE
THAT [inaudible]
WE CAN [inaudible]
SUPPORT [inaudible]
VOUCHERS OR KIND OF A PROGRAM
FOR SUPPORTING GROUP HOMES I
KNOW THAT GROUP HOMES HAVE
CLOSED.
ALL OVER THE STATE IT'S A THE
pBIG PROBLEM RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S THERE'S GROUP HOMES
CLOSING AND THE GROUP HOMES ARE
GOING OUT OF BUSINESS SO THEY
NEED.
THE TO HAVE THEY NEED TO RECRUIT
MORE FAMILIES.
AND I THINK THIS IS MAYBE  WAY
A LOANS OF A MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE
OR SOME OTHER KINDS OF SUPPORT
SYSTEM. FOR FOR OUR FOSTER
FAMILIES COULD BE DEVELOPED THAT
WOULD -- BO A WIN WIN FOR THE
FOSTER CARE BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE
HOUSING. FOR FOSTER YOU NEED TO
HAVE THE HOUSING SO.
I WILL MAKE A MOTION FOR THE
BILL ON THAT BASIS -- MAYBE
THERE'S SOME ISSUES THAT CENTER
PORTANTINO NEEDS TO WORK OUT.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO SUPPORT
FAMILY FOSTER CARE -- A I WAS
JUST TALKING TO MY ONE OF MY A
FORMER STAFF MEMBERS.
WHO WAS A FOSTER?
WAS IN FOSTER CARE ABOUT THIS
VERY SUBJECT.
FRIDAY I HAD A MEETING FRIDAY
JUST TALKING ABOUT THIS VERY
SUBJECT.
HOW?
THERE'S SIMILARLY A BUREAUCRATIC.
TENNESSEE TO SUPPORT
ORGANIZATIONAL GROUP HOMES BUT
NOT FOSTER FAMILY HOMES.
SO I'M GLAD YOU CAME UP WITH
THIS BILL CENTER PORTANTINO.
I THINK WE NEED TO FOLLOW E WE
NEED WE NEED FOR ASSISTANCE THE
WITH OUR STATE POLICY WE SUPPORT.
FAMILY ORIENTED FOSTER CARE.
SO I SUPPORT THE BILL I LIKE
MOTION.
CAN YOU CENTER BUILT IN THE FOR
COMMENTS.
SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU IT SHOULD IT.
I GUESS I AM STILL LOOKING VIEWS
ABOUT HOW THE MECHANISM WOULD
WORK SO YOU CAN EXPLAIN SO WHAT
HAPPENS SO CITY WHICH HAS TO
HAVE ARENA.
HOW WOULD THEY CLAIM THE 5%
CREDIT SO LET ME WALK YOU
THROUGH THE OKAY I WAS HOPING
THAT TO HAVE THE OPTION?
SO RIGHT NOW WHEN THE CITY
PRESENTED HOUSING ELEMENT IT HAS
TO SHOW PLANNED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DOESN'T ACTUALLY HAVE TO
BUILD THE PHONE ABOUT.
HAS TO SHOW THAT THAT THERE'S A
PLAN RIGHT.
AND SO THIS BILL WOULD ONLY.
APPLY TO CITIES THAT HAVE A
CURRENT HOUSING ELEMENT THAT TO
ALREADY APPROVED SO IF YOU'RE A
BAD CITY THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
HOUSING ELEMENT.
YOU'VE TRIED TO GET OUT OF IT.
THIS DOESN'T APPLY SO YOU NUMBER
ONE YOU HAVE TO BE AT A CITY
WITH THE APPROVED PLAN NUMBER.
TWO DURING THE TIME BEFORE YOUR
NEXT PLAN IS APPROVED.
UNLIKE THE ORIGINAL PLAN WHICH
IS HAS TO SHOW THAT YOU CAN PLAN
FOR HOUSING.
IF YOU ACTUALLY PLACE.
FOSTER YOU.
IN SINGLE FAMILY HOMES.
UP 25% OF THAT CAN BE COUNTED
FOR YOUR RENO OBLIGATION WHEN
YOU GO TO RENEW YOUR NEXT POINT.
NOT A THEORETICAL PLAN FOR
PLACING KIDS BUT UP BUT THE THE
IDEAS THAT THIS.
A CHURCH A QANTAS CLUB A PROGRAM
WITHIN A CITY WOULD COME UP AND
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT LET'S.
INCENTIVIZE OUR CONGREGATE IN
OUR OUR COMMUNITY TO PLACE KIDS
IN THESE MONIES AYE BUT I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT.
DETAIL SO [inaudible] FOR EVERY
CHILD EVERY FOSTER CHILD WHOSE
PLACE.
IN THE IN A HOLLOW IN A HOME IN
THE LIMITS OF THE CITY HE LANDED
IN THEIR CITY.
IN THAT PARTICULAR CITY WOULD
CALENDAR THE JURISDICTION OF
THAT HOUSING ELEMENT.
UP 25% SO BUT SO EACH PLACED
WOULD COUNT AS ONE HOUSE RIGHT
SO IF YOU HAD A HUNDRED K. IF
YOU HAD AN OBLIGATION OF EIGHT
HUNDRED OKAY IF YOU PLACED FIVE
CHILDREN IN FIVE HOMES SO LET ME
JUST ASK ANOTHER QUESTION AND SO.
CITIES COME IN DIFFERENT SIZES
RIGHT SUMMER SMALL SOME ARE
LARGER.
I THINK ONE OF OUR PRIORITIES IS
TO BE SURE WE PLACE A FOSTER
YOUTH IN THE RIGHT HOME I MEAN
WE TALK ABOUT PRIORITIES IN
TERMS OF FAMILIES ETCETERA.
SO THEY GET SO AT A WALTERS
EIGHT A CHILD IS PLACED IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM IN ONE CITY.
GETS PLACE WITH A RELATIVE ARE
IN ANOTHER CITY.
WHICH CITY GETS THE CREDIT.
THE CITY THAT'S ABILITY.
OF CURRENT EXISTENCE SO.
HOW DO YOU STRUCTURE STILL TO
RIGHT ALL WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
HELPING AUGMENT THE COUNTIES
EFFORTS TO FIND NEW HOMES?
BY INCENTIVIZING A CITY COUNCIL
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM DESIGNED TO
CLEAR HOME THIS IS A GLORIFIED
SITUATION EXPLAIN IT'S THE CITY.
IN WHICH THE THAT CREATES A
PROBLEM THAT THAT THAT PLATE AND
WHICH IS PLACE SO THIS THAT THEY
HAVE A YOUTH.
NOW THEY WERE WITH ONE FAMILY
MEMBER DAY GOT PLACED IN FOSTER
CARE BECAUSE OF WHATEVER
CIRCUMSTANCES.
RIGHT AND THEN TURNS OUT YEAH
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER I THE THE
SOCIAL WORKER AND A STEP BY THE
BEST POSSIBLE PLACEMENT IS IN
ANOTHER CITY.
THE SUNNIS IN CALIFORNIA THAN --
THAN THAT CITY THAT THAT FAST
YOU THIS PLACE THEN IS THE ONE
WHO QUOTE GETS THE CREDIT RIGHT
AGAINST THEIR ARENA BY BECAUSE
THEY'RE CREATING A NEW HOME.
OKAY THE IDEA IS TO CREATE A NEW
FOSTER.
HOME.
AND INCENTIVIZE PLACING CHILDREN
IN THESE HOMES OKAY SO THIS IS A
CITY IT'S SELF NEED TO DO I MEAN
IDEALLY I THINK YOU TRY COURAGE
CITIES.
THE REST IS FIVE ALA TERRY BUT
BUT I MEAN IT COULD BE THAT JUST
PASSIVELY THIS.
THE SERBS THEIR NUMBER WILL
HAPPEN RIGHT JUST BECAUSE THE
COUNTIES WORKING TO PLACE THESE
FOSTER YOUTH YEAH THERE WILL BE
SOME PLACE WHERE BUT AS AL SAID
WERE RUNNING SHORT.
OF OPPORTUNITIES NOW I KNOW AND
IN PARTICULAR SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES DON'T.
HAVE VERY LIMITED NUMBER OF FOSS
AND THAT'S THE OTHER PART OF
THIS IS TRYING TO CREATE.
SORT OF NONTRADITIONAL.
PLACEMENTS IN IN HOMES THAT
WOULD NORMALLY DO THIS BY
CREATING A LOCAL VOLUNTARY AFTER
THAT THE WHOLE THEORY BEHIND
OKAY ALL RIGHT AND I DON'T WANT
TO REWARD A PLAN.
I WANT TO REWARD ACTION RIGHT
RIGHT PLACEMENT OKAY AND AND OUR
HOUSING CHAIR SITS ON THE
COMMITTEE UNDERSTAND WENT
THROUGH HOUSING AND HOUSING HIS
PERSPECTIVE ON HOW BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THIS.
THE HOW THE IMPACTS ARE FOR WILL
HOUSING PLANS BUT DAY APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT IT DID PASS
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE ALREADY SO
IF I GET RID AND I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR FOR SENATOR WIENER BUT
WE DID TAKE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT OKAY.
OKAY SUGGEST ADDING ONE MOST
PROMINENT ONE BEING IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY YOU HAVE TO BE A CITY
WITH AN APPROVED HOUSING HEALTH.
OKAY EVEN START OKAY AS I I
THOUGHT THAT WAS A GOOD A GOOD
AMENDMENT OKAY I JUST WANT TO
CLEAR OKAY THIS THANK YOU HAVE A
BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW YOU BILLS
BEFORE THANK YOU.
CENTERS HAVE ONE QUESTION HOW
WERE -- COUNTY IS GOING TO BE
COMMUNICATING WITH CITIES THAT
THEY PLACE X. AMOUNT OF KIDS
INTO HOMES SO THAT THEY CAN
RELATE OR CREDIT THROUGH THE
NORMAL PROCESS I MEAN COUNTIES
THAT PLACE KIDS IN.
HOMES NOW HAVE A COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE HOST AND THE COUNTY
THERE NOTHING'S CHANGING THAT
BUT SOMEONE UP BEHIND IT BUT AS
A CITY BECAUSE SERENA CREDIT
RIGHT THE CITY WILL GET ON IT
CREDIT HOW ARE THEY GOING TO
KNOW.
THAT THE COUNTY IS PLACED A
CHILD IN THEIR JURISDICTION SO
THEY CAN CLAIM BUT PART OF THIS
IS EDUCATING THE CITY'S RIGHT TO
KNOW WHAT'S THIS TOOL IS
AVAILABLE IF THE BILL GETS
SIGNED.
YOU KNOW WILL WORK THROUGH THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES WILL MAKE SURE
THAT CITIES ARE.
ARE MADE AWARE OF THIS NEW.
YOU KNOW.
HOUSING TOOL I MEAN THAT'S MY
WHOLE SO MAYBE SHOULD TAKE A
MOMENT SO THIS BILL -- I WANT TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY THE THIRD SOME
TYPE OF A COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE COUNTY AND THE RECOGNIZE
BENEFICIARY CITY BECAUSE I WANT
THEM TO GET THAT CREDIT
ABSOLUTELY AND WE WANT TO CITIES
TO KNOW ABOUT THIS SO THEY CAN.
YOU KNOW AND WHEN WE ARE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT MR WIENER.
SUGGEST WAS GOING FROM 10% 25% I
WAS FINE WITH THAT I JUST WANT
TO SEE IF.
THE INCENTIVE WORKS YOU KNOW AND
SEE IF WE CAN ACTUALLY GET KIDS
AT HOME IT'S A VERY AND IT'S NOT
ABOUT HOW MANY IT'S ABOUT
WHETHER THIS WORKS -- SO THANKS
YOUR CREATIVITY -- WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR BELL WHICH I
CAN EXACTLY YES RIVAL SO WITH
HIS -- DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
RICARDO STONE BY STONE AYE BELL.
BELL I'D JACKSON PAN.
HI PAN AYE WIENER. THREE ZERO
THREE ZERO THAT'LL STAY ON CALL
SENATOR CONGRATULATIONS
[inaudible]
WIENER GLAZER.
SENATOR GLAZER SB.
THREE SEVENTY FOUR I'LL POINT
OUT THIS -- DOES HAVE SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU A THIS DEVICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
A LOT OF FIRST BEGIN BY THANKING
THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL.
THEY MAKE A NUMBER OF
SUGGESTIONS AND RAISE A NUMBER
OF ISSUES THAT I'M COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THEM ON
IF THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
BUT THIS LEGISLATION WOULD ALLOW
STUDENTS PARENTS ON CAL WORKS TO
CONTINUE RECEIVING FULL BENEFITS
THROUGH THE PROGRAM AS LONG AS
THEY REMAIN IN GOOD ACADEMIC
STANDING.
BILL ALSO REQUIRES COUNTY
WELFARE DEPARTMENTS PROVIDE THE
STUDENT PARENTS WITH FUNDS TO
PURCHASE BOOKS.
PRIOR TO THE BEGINNING OF THEIR
ACADEMIC TERM.
COLLEGE STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
ARE EXPERIENCING UNPRECEDENTED
LEVELS OF HOUSING AND FOOD IN
SECURITY.
MAKING A COLLEGE EDUCATION LESS
ACCESSIBLE ESPECIALLY FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS.
A COLLEGE EDUCATION IS EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN FOR STUDENTS
PARENTS STUDENT PARENTS ON CAL
WORKS.
STUDENT PARENTS ON CAL WORKS ARE
OFTEN REQUIRED TO WORK AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY TO THIRTY
HOURS. TO RECEIVE FULL POWER
BENEFITS.
NOT ONLY IS IT DIFFICULT TO BE A
PARENT.
FULL TIME COLLEGE STUDENT AND
WORK TWENTY TO THIRTY HOURS ALL
THE SAME TIME.
BUT OF A STUDENT PARENT ON CAL
WORKS IS NOT MEET THE WORK
REQUIREMENTS.
THEY DO NOT NEED IT.
THEY CAN HAVE THEIR BENEFITS
REDUCED.
THIS EFFECTIVELY PUNISHES LOW
INCOME PARENTS FOR SEEKING A
COLLEGE EDUCATION THINK ABOUT
THAT.
THE POLICY THAT'S IN PLACE TODAY.
DISCRIMINATES AGAINST THE PARENT.
FULL TIME COLLEGE STUDENT.
TRYING TO GET AN EDUCATION.
THE ONLY FORTY EIGHT MONTHS OF
ELIGIBILITY ON CAL WORKS
AVAILABLE IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT WE
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS PARENTS
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO COMPLETE
THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION. FOR
THEIR ELIGIBILITY AND CAL WORK
WORKS ENDS.
FURTHERMORE MANY CAL WORK
STUDENT PARENTS FACE BARRIERS TO
PURCHASING THE REQUIRED
TEXTBOOKS FOR THEIR CLASSES
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT RECEIVE
THEIR BOOK FUNDS FROM THE COUNTY
AND TIME.
IN THIS SCENARIO STUDENTS MAKE
THE DECISION TO PUT OFF BUYING
THEIR BOOKS THINK ABOUT THAT.
THEY PUT OFF BUYING THEIR BOOKS
UNTIL THEY CAN RECEIVE THE MONEY
WHICH PUTS THEM BEHIND -- IN
THEIR COURSE WORK.
OR THEY BUY THEIR BOOKS WITH
THEIR OWN FUNDS RUN CREDIT
FINANCIALLY STRAINING THEMSELVES
EVEN FURTHER.
THIS BILL PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY
FOR CAL WORKS RECIPIENTS THAT
WANT TO BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT
BY GETTING A COLLEGE EDUCATION
WELL STREAMLINING THE PROCESS
FOR IN WHICH THEY RECEIVE FUNDS
TO PURCHASE THEIR TEXTBOOKS.
THREE SEVENTY FOUR HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT SUPPORTED BY
GREAT COALITION STUDENT GROUPS
SOME OF WHOM ARE HERE.
TRAVELED A LONG WAYS WHICH I
APPRECIATE.
AND NUMBER OF ANTI POVERTY
ORGANIZATIONS WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
JOINING ME TO TESTIFY IS KEVIN
HAS LION.
FROM THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION AND
JOANNA REYES WALTON THAT PHD
CANDIDATE FROM UCLA THANK YOU
BOTH FOR BEING HERE.
WELCOME THANK YOU DRAFTING
COMMITTEE AND AS YOUTH CENTER
STATED MY NAME IS JOANNA REYES
WALTON AND A PHD CANDIDATE AT
UCLA -- I'M ALSO A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT AND
SINGLE MOTHER TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
THREE SEVEN FOUR HIGHER
EDUCATION WAS SUPPOSED TO BE WAY
OUT OF FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY AND
A PATH TO A BETTER LIFE FOR MY
FAMILY.
BUT SINCE I BEGAN MY GRADUATE
EDUCATION I'VE FACED ALMOST
INSURMOUNTABLE FINANCIAL
BARRIERS.
ON A GOOD MONTH TO RENT OUT MY
UNIVERSITIES FAMILY HOUSING
TAKES NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF MY
INCOME AND SOMETIMES EVEN UP
280%.
SO LIKE MANY OF MY FELLOW PEERS
I'M A SINGLE MOTHER MOTHER OF
COLOR TRYING TO SUCCEED AT
SCHOOL AND AS A PARENT.
AND I'M ON WELFARE.
I RELY ON CAL FOR US TO BUY
ENOUGH NUTRITIOUS FOOD TO FEED
MYSELF AND MY CHILDREN AND THEY
RECEIVE HEALTH COVERAGE THROUGH
MEDICARE BECAUSE I CANNOT AFFORD
THE DEPENDENT COVERAGE THROUGH
MY UNIVERSITY.
I WOULD HAVE RELIED ON CAL WORKS
AS WELL WERE IT NOT FOR THE
EXTREMELY ARDUOUS OUTDATED AND
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS AND
BARRIERS THAT THIS PROGRAM
IMPOSES UPON STUDENT PARENTS WHO
RECEIVE THIS BENEFIT.
AS IT STANDS IF I WERE CAO WORKS
RECIPIENT I WOULD NEED TO
PHYSICALLY REPORT TO THE COUNTY
ON A WELFARE DEPARTMENT EVERY
TIME MY CLASS SCHEDULE CHANGES.
EVERY TIME A TAKE OR T. A. A
DIFFERENT CLASS AND EVERY TIME
THERE'S A SINGLE CHANGE IN
ANYTHING REGARDING MY ACADEMIC
RECORDS.
YOU CAN HARDLY IMAGINE HOW MUCH
OF A BURDEN THAT PTS ON ME AND
MY PEERS WHO BETWEEN SUPPORTING
OUR FAMILIES AND PURSUING OR
EDUCATION.
DO NOT HAVE THE TIME TO NAVIGATE
THESE KINDS OF BUREAUCRATIC
BARRIERS.
THAT'S WHY I SUPPORT SB.
THREE SEVEN FOUR THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT STUDENT PARENTS
LIKE MYSELF CAN RECEIVE THE MUCH
NEEDED BENEFITS OF CAL WORKS AND
BE ABLE TO FOCUS ON EDUCATION AS
THE PATHWAY OF UPWARD MOBILITY.
AND THE KEY TO MOVING OUT OF THE
WELFARE SYSTEM FOR GOOD.
A GOOD STUDENT.
A GREAT PARENT AND TO KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING FRAGILE.
ALL THE CHALLENGES YOU'RE FACING
AND GETTING HER PHD.
THE LA LA.
TREASURY U. S. C. BUT WHAT WHEN
YOU'RE TO UCLA.
PLAY BOTH SIDES CONGRATULATIONS
WERE DELIGHTED YOU'RE HERE.
PLEASE CONTINUE A KEVIN AS A
COLUSA CALIFORNIA WHAT PROVIDES
ORGANIZATIONS.
WITH DOING THIS FOR A LONG TIME
IT'S VERY HARD WITH STUDENTS.
ON CAL WORKS TO TO GET AN
EDUCATION OFTEN THIS BARRIERS IN
THE PERRANCE MEAN SANCTIONS
THANKS A MEANS.
FAMILY OF TO YOUR BENEFITS
MONTHLY BENEFIT OF FIVE SEVENTY
SEVEN GOES DOWN. IFTY FIVE A
MONTH AND IT'S A DISASTER -- WE
BASICALLY ARE.
JUST GIVE SIX TO SEVEN HUNDRED
MORE MILLION DOLLARS.
A HIGHER EDUCATION AND WELFARE
RECIPIENTS SHOULD HAVE EQUAL
ACCESS TO THAT.
AND WITH THE THE CASE MANAGEMENT
THE SUN AND THE COLLEGE.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO TO WELL
FOR THE PUBLIC TO GET KIDS
MEASURE BECAUSE IS OFFERING.
VERY COMPETENT AND ABLE CONSULS
IN THE COLLEGE WHO COULD HELP
THEM OUT AND I WILL CHEN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THEY GIVE HER
TESTIMONY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
AGAIN MY NAME IS JOSEPH BERRY --
AS A PERSON GREW UP IN EXTREME
POVERTY AND AND AND AND RECEIVE
NOT JUST FULL STANCE BUT BUT CAO
WORKS AT THAT TIME WAS WELFARE
AND FOOD STAMPS IF YOU WILL.
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT IT IS --
LIKE THE YOUNG LADY HERE SOME
WHOSE -- TRANSITIONING FROM YOU
KNOW BLUFF PROPERTY AND TO A
GRADUATE TYPE OF DEGREE OF THESE
PROGRAMS I QUE SE -- DO ENOUGH --
TO I WOULD SAY THESE PROGRAMS
SAVE -- SUCH TYPES OF RULES
WITHIN THESE PROGRAMS.
THE PROHIBIT PERSONS FROM TRY TO
BETTER THEMSELVES IF YOU WILL
THEY ACT AS A PROHIBITIVE FACTOR
FOR US TO MAKE A WAY IN WHICH
OUR LIVES ARE SUFFICIENT AS FAR
AS FINANCIALLY.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS -- I
SUPPORT THIS BILL HARDLY THANK
YOU JOSEPH THANK YOU FOR THE
NEXT -- PLEASE.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
PORTION OF ASSEMBLY WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION WHEN A
STRONG SUPPORTER AND I THANK YOU
TO SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE UP -- WE'RE VERY
PROUD TO BE WORKING WITH YOU ON
IT AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
THIS WAY.
HI ELAINE I THEN GO IN SUPPORT
ON A CO FOUNDER OF MOTHER'S OF
COLOR IN A CLEAN ORGANIZED ALONG
WITH JOANNA.
AND ALSO STUDENT AT UCLA.
HELLO MY NAME IS DIANA CRUZ
REBUS AND I AM MAKE -- FOR CAL
OF NIGHT A UC BERKELEY AND I
STRUGGLED -- GOING TO SCHOOL
WITH THREE LITTLE ONES -- I WAS
A DENTAL ASSISTANT AND CARPAL
TUNNEL AND I HAD TO RETURN BACK
TO SCHOOL.
AND SO ARE YOU SUPPORT THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT WOULD HELP A LOT OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE MY SITUATION
[inaudible]
SIR.
MY NAME'S DANIEL REVERSE OF AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT UC DAVIS.
OF AN OFFICER FOR OLDER WISER
LEARNERS -- AS SOON ORGANIZATION
THAT'S COMPRISED OF REENTRY
STUDENTS AND MAGNER SCHOLAR.
THAN A STANDARD SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK GOD THERE'S THERE'S PART.
AND I'M JEFF TORTILLA AN
ADVOCATE.
AND THIS IS WHAT GOT ME IN HERE
IN TO TALKING TO YOU GUYS
BECAUSE I HAD THE DISABILITY
COORDINATOR.
AT SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE SAY
JEFF I NEED HELP FOR FUNDING.
SO -- SUPPORT OF THIS BECAUSE IN
NEW THE PROBLEM THERE I HAVE
WORKED ON BOTH THE FOR FOOD
BANKS AND THE OTHER PROGRAMS.
AND WINTER SAYS SANCTUARY AND
OTHER THINGS THROUGH HERE SO NO
DECREE I OBSERVE IT SEX STATE OF
HOW MANY STUDENTS HAVE THAT NEED
AND SO WE GOT THE FOOD BANK IN
THERE.
SO YES I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS THANK YOU FOR TESTIMONY OF
THEIRS IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE COME FORWARD.
IF NOT IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION SB.
THREE SEVENTY FOUR XENON COMING
BACK TO MY FELLOW SENATORS
[inaudible]
CENTER PAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I
APPRECIATE THAT THE THIS --
YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE I GUESS I WENT QUESTIONS
AN ANALYSIS.
IT THAT DOES MAKE MENTION
THERE'S A CURRENT THERE'S A
CURRENT MECHANISM -- IN WHICH
DHEA FUNNY FOR FOOT TALL AND
SLICE EXPENSES THAT INCLUDES
BOOKS AND TRANSPORTATION WHICH
CAN BE ADVANCED -- FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE.
COMPLETING THEIR WELFARE TO WORK
ACTIVITIES SO HOW HOW DOES THIS --
BILL INTERFACE WITH WITH WITH
THAT MECHANISM I MEAN THAT OF
JUST WHAT TRAFFIC OUT SO WE
DON'T HAVE MULTIPLE MECHANISMS
WHICH CREATE CAN CREATE EVEN
MORE CONFUION AS TO ITS GREAT
WE CAN.
TRY TO SUPPORT MORE PEOPLE BUT
YOU KNOW IF YOU DO NOT HAVE
MULTIPLE MECHANISMS THAT COULD
CREATE CONFUSION AS TO HOW TO
GET SUPPORT SELL PRICES OF THE
FIGHT NIGHT INCREASED COMPLEXITY.
THE KEVIN OTHER QUARTERS
CALIFORNIA FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS CURRENTLY WHAT
HAPPENS WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
STUDENTS.
WHO START GOING TO COLLEGE AND
THEY CAN'T GET THE BOOKS PAID
THE SUBMIT ALL OF THE
VERIFICATION THROUGH WELFARE
SYSTEM?
BUT IT GETS HUNG UP IN THE PLAKA
SEE AN UP TO TWO WEEKS TO HAVE
TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL I'VE SEEN
WOMAN ACTUALLY DROPPED OUT OF
SCHOOL AND NEVER TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL AGAIN.
AND AND JUST TO THE LEFT TO
INVESTMENT SHATTERED WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO WOULD FIFTEEN DAYS
BEFORE THE BEGINNING OF THE
SEMESTER WOULD GIVE UNDER THE
VANCE CHECK OF FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS TO BUY BOOKS.
AFTER THAT HE WILL PROVIDE
VERIFICATION AND WE WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE STAFF TO AMEND THE
BILL.
THAT THE STORY WOULD HAVE TO
PROVIDE VERIFICATION OF HOW THEY
SPEND THE MONEY.
AND THE FOR COST MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS THEN THE ACCOUNT
THEN THE COUNTY WOULD REIMBURSE
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO SHOW HOW
THEY SPEND THE MONEY IS THAT THE
SPONSOR.
OKAY WELL OUT OF THE ME TRY TO
ENHANCE A LITTLE BIT WHICH IS
THAT THERE ARE.
THIS PROVIDES ANOTHER OPTION
SENATOR THAT YES THERE THERE IS
A SUPPORT -- SERVICES FOR
ANCILLARY EXPENSES THIS TRIES TO
CREATE A PROTOCOL FOR HOW THEY
CAN GET PAYMENT EARLY.
WITH THE REQUIREMENT FOR
RECEIPTS -- DEPEND TO BUY BOOKS
BUT THAT IT'S NOT MY INTENTION
TO CREATE THAT COMPLEXITY SOME
VERY COMMITTED TO IF THAT IF
THAT THIS OVERLAY CREATES THAT
CONFUSION IS NOT SOMETHING ANY
OF THIS WASHER AND ARE COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE
STAFF TO MAKE SURE THAT ISN'T
THE CASE.
OKAY AND AND AND AND AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE AND THEY
KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT YOUR
ATTENTION SO I JUST I JUST WANT
TO THINK ABOUT HOW THE SITS IN
THE LARGER SCHEME SO. FOR
EXAMPLE -- A AND I THINK EITHER
OF US RISING BECAUSE AT THE OF
THE PRESENTED BEFORE BUDGETS OF
THREE EVERY TIME OF OVERSEEING
THIS I'M THINKING OKAY.
NOW THIS VERY SAME SOCIAL WORKER
WHO'S SUPPOSED TO BE MOVING THE
MONEY UP FRONT ON THE ANSWER
SERVICES IS THE SAME ONE WHO IS
GOING TO BE SIGNING OFF FIFTEEN
DAYS BEFORE.
AND SO IN SOME SENSESI THINK
PART OF IT IS TRY TO FIGURE OUT --
AT AND I WANT THIS BUILDING
BEFORE BUT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BE MOST EFFECTIVELY GET THE
FUNDS TO THE STUDENTS IN A
TIMELY MANNER.
YOU FROM OUT FUNDS IT ALSO
MINIMIZE THE AMOUNT I GUESS
MICHAEL OVERHEAD -- THAT THAT
WILL HAPPEN IN TERMS OF
APPROVALS CLIMB BACK MONEY AND
SO FORTH SO -- AT IT AND SO I DO
SO -- HOPE THAT YOU CAN TRY TO
WORK ON LOOK AT THESE MECHANISMS
HOW TO BRING TOGETHER FOR
EXAMPLE MAYBE IT IS GOING TO BE
A DAD MAYBE MORE ABOUT SAYING
THAT.
YELLED HERE SOME GUIDELINES ON
LIKE ON THE IT'S A SERVICES YOU
NEED TO ADVANCE THE MONEY BY
CERTAIN DEADLINE OR SOMETHING.
AND THEN TRY TO INSTEAD OF GOING
TO WHAT THEY'RE DOING NOW SO
JUST BE SURE WE TAKE THESE TWO
PROCESSES AND FIND A WAY THIS.
BRING THEM TOGETHER IN A WAY
LIKE ED AND MAKE THEM AND AND
AND SO THAT BECAUSE THIS PROCESS
DOESN'T WORK DOESN'T AS A MEAN
WE ALWAYS CREATE A BRAND NEW ONE
BUT WHAT WE DO IS.
BUT THE NEW RULES ON THE OLD ONE
TO MAKE THAT WORK USING THINGS
THAT WE KNOW SO FOR EXAMPLE
MAYBE THEY NEED TO ADVANCE MONEY.
AND THEN RECLAIM THIS IS THE
MECHANISM USING NOW IN THAT
PROCESS VERSUS SAYING WE HAVE
THIS PROCESS HERE WE HAVE THAT
PROCESS THERE AND SO ANYWAY I I
WILL URGE YOU TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT.
THANK YOU THE AUTHORS COMMITTED
TO DOING SO ABSOLUTELY SENATOR
BILL MOOS THE BILL -- CENTERED
RESERVE ELECT MAKE ANY FINAL
COMMENTS THANK YOU FOR HEARING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE THAT AFFECTS SO
MANY MORE THAN YOU THINK.
AND THESE ARE PERSONAL STORIES
THAT THE ARE VERY POWERFUL.
WHEN YOU SEE HOW THAT ROAD BLOCK?
ON A PROGRAM THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE HELPING ACTUALLY STOPS THEM
FROM IMPROVING THEIR LIVES TO A
HIGHER EDUCATION DEGREE I THANK
OUR WITNESSES AND THE FOLKS FROM
UCLA FOR COMING UP.
AND SENATOR PANZA POINTS -- I
KNOW WERE -- FROM WISDOM AND
EXPERIENCE AND AND AND WELL MADE
AND WILL WORK TO DO OUR BEST.
TO TO PROVIDE THE SAME RESULT WE
BOTH MUTUALLY WHAT.
THIS IS THE PAST APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO STONE BY STONE HI BILL.
WELL I JACKSON PAN RIGHT PAN I
WINNER. THREE ZERO THREE ZERO
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN SENATOR
ON MONEY.
SB
[inaudible]
FOUR THIRTY THREE GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
GET SOME WITNESSES JOINING US
HERE.
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL FOR THIRTY THREE WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH A THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM FOR THREE TO FIVE
COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA. TO
CREATE OFFICES OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION.
THESE OFFICES WILL BE MODELED IN
PART AFTER LOS ANGELES TWO
COUNTIES NEWLY CREATED AN
EXISTING OFFICE OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DIVERSION.
WILL ALLOW PARTICIPATING
COUNTIES TO EXPLORE PUBLIC
HEALTH CENTERED APPROACHES TO
USE JUSTICE ISSUES WHEN YOU
THINK CALIFORNIA ARRESTED FOR
LOW LEVEL OFFENSES AND FORCED
INTO INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THEY'RE OFTEN INFLICTED WITH
FURTHER HARM IN AN INCREASED
RISK OF RECIDIVISM.
JUSTICE INVOLVED USE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY CHILDREN OF
COLOR FOSTER CHILDREN IN USE WHO
IDENTIFIES LGBT Q..
AN OFTEN COME FROM BACKGROUNDS
WHERE THEY'VE BEEN EXPOSED TO
ABUSE ABANDONMENT NEGLECT IN
TRAUMA THAT INFLUENCES THEIR
BEHAVIOR.
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM IS NOT
PREPARED ARE DESIGNED TO ADDRESS
THESE HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT
ISSUES IN RESEARCH HAS SHOWN.
THAT A CRAM A CRIMINAL JANICK
ROACH. TO DEALING WITH USED
TYPICALLY DOES NOTHING TO
ADDRESS THE UNDERLYING ISSUES
THAT DRIVE A YOUNG PERSON TO
OFFEND.
SP FOUR THIRTY THREE WILL ALLOW
INTERESTED PILOT COUNTIES TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS YOUTH JUSTICE
ISSUES THROUGH TRAUMA INFORMED
CULTURALLY RELEVANT PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES.
THAT ARE AGE APPROPRIATE AND IT
EMPHASIS EMPHASISE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING.
THE PILOT OFFICES OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DIVERSION WILL ACT
AS A CENTRAL POINT OF
COORDINATION FOR COMMUNITY BASED%
ORGANIZATIONS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND COUNTY AGENCIES AND WILL
WORK TO BLAND EXISTING COUNTY
HEALTH SERVICES.
AND COMMUNITY BASED INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS TO BETTER ADDRESS THE
EFFECTS OF TRAUMA.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES ON JUSTICE
INVOLVED TO USE.
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
EXPLICITLY REQUIRE THE
COLLABORATION INCLUSION OF
COUNTY PROBATION DEPARTMENTS IN
THE WORK DONE BY THESE PILOT
OFFICES.
AND WILL IN NO WAY PREVENT
PROBATION FROM CARRYING OUT
THEIR EXISTING PROGRAMS.
MOST OFTEN WITH USE WHO ARE
ALREADY CHARGED IN IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
MEMBERS THIS MEASURE IS A
VOLUNTARY IN TIME LIMITED PILOT
PROGRAM THAT WILL ALLOW A
HANDFUL OF COUNTIES TO EXPLORE
NEW PATHWAYS IN ADDRESSING YOUTH
JUSTICE ISSUES.
THROUGH A PUBLIC HEALTH PLANS.
I ASK THAT YOU JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING OUR JUSTICE INVOLVES
YOUTH WITH COUNSELING IN
SERVICES INSTEAD OF HAND CUFFS
IN JAIL CELLS.
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME MISTER CHAIR OF
A COUPLE OF WITNESSES HERE TO
TEST BUT I WITH PERMISSION OF
THE CHAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ON I THINK WE'LL START
WITH -- TAYLOR SCHOOLING IN PH
WAS SANDERS COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH SERVICES WELCOME.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- HELLO
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I AM THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US HERE --
AND FOR LETTING ME SHARE WITH
YOU -- SOME OF WHAT WE LEARNED
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT WHY WHEN
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES EQUITABLY AND
EFFECTIVELY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IN
ANY GIVEN JURISDICTION -- A
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH TO TRUE
JUSTICE SYSTEM TRANSFORMATION IS
KEY AND AND AND IMPORTANCE.
I AM I AM A PUBLIC HEALTH
RESEARCHER AN EVALUATOR BY
TRAINING AND I WILL HELP TO
LEAVE OUT OF REAL COLLABORATIVE
CROSS SECTOR -- GOVERNMENT
COMMUNITY AT LAW ENFORCEMENT
COURT A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS.
PROCESS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THAT RESULTED IN THE
ESTABLISHMENT OUR OFFICE OF
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND DIVERSION --
LAST YEAR.
THAT YEAR OF PLANNING THAT WE
UNDERTOOK REALLY TOLD US -- THAT
THE MISSING PIECE IN A IN A
COLLECTION -- EFFORTS TO REFORM
OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM TRANSFORM
OUR APPROACH TO YOUTH JUSTICE --
WAS IN PART A CENTRALIZED WHOLE
FOCUS COORDINATION -- OF A REAL
HEALING INFORMED COMMERCE
SPONSORS AND YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
CENTERED APPROACH TO KEEPING
YOUNG PEOPLE OUT OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AT THE EARLIEST POSSIBLE
POINT OF CONTACT.
THE WE LEARNED I AM IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH.
YOUNG PEOPLE AND COMMUNITY
MEMBERS LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
AND COMMUNITY BASED SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO SERVE YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT WHAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT
WAS THIS VERY EARLY OPPORTUNITY
FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN
THE FIELD -- TO REFER YOUNG
PEOPLE TO COMMUNITY BASED
PARTNERS WHO WERE SUPPORTED IN
TAKING A HEALTH AND HEALING
APPROACH TO THE YOUNG PEOPLE
THEY SERVED.
I AM THE BENEFITS OF OF HOUSING
THIS IN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY THIS TYPE OF
COORDINATION.
AS WE LEARNED IN LA -- WITH OUR
COLLABORATIVE GROUP OF
STAKEHOLDERS.
INCLUDED THE FOLLOWING ONE AND
THAT THIS ALLOWED THE
PRIORITIZATION OF SUSTAINABLE
COUNTY RESOURCES FOR SOLUTIONS
THAT ADDRESS ROOT CAUSES AS THE
SENATOR MENTIONED THAT ARE TRULY
CAPABLE OF IMPROVING.
THE LIVES OF YOUNG PEOPLE. TO
THEM THAT A PUBLIC HEALTH
APPROACH TO THIS TYPE OF EARLY
DIVERSION -- CONNECTS OTHERWISE
SILO DEFECTORS WITH COMMUNITY
AND BOTH SORT OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE MOST IMPACTED BY THE
WORK -- THAT IT IN A WAY THAT
BUILDS BY AN AND AVOIDS ANY
UNANTICIPATED HARMS OF SORT OF
MISSION DRIFTING -- IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM MORE BRINGING
PEOPLE UNDER THAT THE BURDEN
FROM SYSTEMS THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
STREAMLINE.
AND AVOID WHENEVER POSSIBLE --
AND THEN THIRD I AM THAT THIS
TYPE OF COORDINATION WOULD ALLOW
FOR THE SUPPORT OF ONGOING
RESEARCH AND EVALUATION.
THAT WOULD KEEP ALL SYSTEMS
ACCOUNTABLE TO LONG TERM
IMPROVEMENT AND THE SORT OF
PLUGGING INTO HEALTH RESEARCH
WHAT ALLOWS US ALL TO LOOK AT A
WIDE RANGE OF YOUTH OUTCOMES NOT
JUST RECIDIVISM.
BUT ALSO HEALTH ACADEMIC -- AND
OTHER OUTCOMES AT THAT TRULY
TELL US HOW YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
DOING.
I'M FINALLY I'LL JUST SAY THAT --
YOU KNOW OUR EXPERIENCE THAT WAY
I THINK IT'S REALLY HIGHLIGHTED
BY -- RECENT LITERATURE RESEARCH
EVIDENCE FOR ANY HE FEE
FOUNDATIONS TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT TITLED TRANSFORMING
JUVENILE PROBATION FOR EXAMPLE --
FURTHER SUPPORTS WHAT WE LEARNED
IN LA THEY STATED THAT DIVERSION
QUOTE SHOULD BE HANDLED BY
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE COMMUNITY.
AND OR PUBLIC HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY OUTSIDE THE COURT SYSTEM --
THIS COMMITMENT TO TAKING A A
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH TO THIS
TRANSFORMATION -- IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY HAS BEEN A REAL JOY TO
WATCH AND EXPERIENCE ITS LEAD TO
UNPRECEDENTED COLLABORATION
BETWEEN GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
ADVOCATES AND YOUNG PEOPLE AND
AND HAS GIVEN US A REAL INFORMED
FOUNDATION FROM WHICH TO MAKE A
REAL COMMUNITY DRIVEN CHANGE AND
I AM THRILLED AT THE IDEA THAT
THAT MORE JURISDICTIONS WOULD --
EMBARK ON THE JOURNEY.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT WITNESS WILL
BEING ANTHONY ROEBLING SEES A
FORMER JUSTICE INVOLVED USE WITH
THE YOUTH JUSTICE COALITION AND
JUST BEFORE HE TESTIFIES MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
JUST LIKE TO INTRODUCE DARIA
ALLIES LARRY'S SAYS THEY WHO'S
HERE AND AS AN ATTORNEY WITH THE
YOUTH JUSTICE INITIATIVE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW.
AS RESOURCE PERSONALLY TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
PLEASE MR ROBUST THANK YOU
SENATOR HOME HELLO CHEN MEMBERS
OF SORRY MY BACK IS TURNED TO
LOOK.
AT EQUALLY.
TALKING ON ALL OF YOU SOME MONEY
THAT THE ROAD IS THAT THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION AND WE WERE
ONE OF THE LEADING -- COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELP DEVELOP
AND AND HELPING IMPLEMENT THAT
YOU -- THAT VERSION AND
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT I LIKE
COUNTY -- AND FOR ME I'VE BEEN
PERSONALLY IMPACTED BECAUSE WHEN
I WAS FIRST ARRESTED I WAS ABOUT
TWELVE OR THIRTEEN AND WHEN I
WAS ARRESTED.
WHO I COULD HAVE BEEN DIVERTED
BUT THERE WAS NO PROGRAM THERE'S
NO DIVERSION ANYTHING AT THE
TIME?
AND WHEN I WAS ARRESTED I WAS
INSULTED BY THE POLICE THEY TOLD
ME I WOULD NEVER MAKE IT IN
JUVENILE HALL AND CHALLENGING I
GUESS LIKE MY MASCULINITY AND
THINGS LIKE THAT AND MAKING ME
REALLY FILL.
ON THIS CUT YOU MY SELF ESTEEM --
BECAUSE OF THAT ARREST -- THAT
SENT ME ON A PATH TOWARDS ON A
PIPELINE INTO THE JAIL SYSTEM
INSTEAD OF ALLOWING ME TO FOLLOW
MY DREAMS WHEN I TURNED EIGHTEEN
I WANT TO JOIN THE MILITARY.
AND WHEN I WENT TO TALK TO
RECRUITERS I EVEN DID THE AS OF
AB TEST AND ALSO GUN BILL ON MY
SCORED A NINETY FOUR ONE THAT
HAS THAT THEY WANTED ME TO SIGN
UP THE NEXT DAY AND WHEN THEY
DID THE LIVE SCAN.
I COULD ENJOY AND BECAUSE OF MY
ARM JUVENILE RECORD IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE OF THAT FOR
SERVICE IN THE HOUSE ON TWELVE
OR THIRTEEN I COULD ENJOYING --
BUT IF I HAD A GOOD DIVERSION
PROGRAM I COULD HAVE AVOIDED
THAT RECORD IN COULD OF AND TO
THE MILITARY'S I HOPE AND I WAS --
EIGHTEEN AND IN LA LA COUNTY IS
THE FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON WE'VE HAD MEETINGS
WERE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO.
LED THE MEETINGS -- CREATED THE
AGENDAS AND IT'S HELPED INFORM
THE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES IN THE
THE C. BEALS YOUTH SERVING.
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT WHAT WE NEED
OR WHAT THE YOUNG PEOPLE NEED
WHO ARE CURRENTLY GOING TO THESE
THINGS WHAT THEY NEED AND WHAT
WHAT A WHAT A WHAT IDEAL YOU ON
TELEVISION AND DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT WOULD LOOK LIKE AN
ALLEY COUNTY IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
AT LEAST TWELVE THOUSAND YOUNG
PEOPLE BE.
DIVERTED FROM THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND ON ONE THING THAT WE'VE BEEN
FIGHTING -- FOR LOCALLY IS A
ROBUST YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
REPRESENTATION TO THE SIDE ABOUT
WELL I'M HOW FUNDS ARE USING
WHAT THE PROGRAMS LOOK LIKE
FLOATING COURAGE THAT ARM AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL IS
SIGNED INTO LAW.
AND TO SEPARATE TO HAVE A
COMPLETE SEPARATION.
HOME FROM THE D. DIVERSION
DEVELOPMENT FROM PROBATION AND
ANY OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
INCLUDING DATA AND PROGRESS
REPORTS AND THINGS LIKE THAT THE
YOUNG PEOPLE.
HELLO AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND PLEASE VOTE YES.
THANK YOU REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
VERY OTHERS AS PART OF THIS
BEFORE THIRTY THREE PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
BORN REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS IN FULL
SUPPORT -- CARRIES WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT HE WAS MINE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE I BELIEVE PROMOTED
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY IS
EVERYONE'S JOB.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ISAAC DOORS AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MANY OF THE TORONTO GARDEN I
SUPPORT THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANAGEMENT HOW FAMILY SERVICES
YOUTH INTERVENTION SPECIALIST
AND I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S AT SEVEN DOLLARS LESS
SUPPORTIVE THOUGH THANK YOU.
IN THIS MENACE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
EMILY ALEXA PAEAN EUSTACE'S
COALITION BROTHER SINCE OF
COALITION AND A STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
THOSE VERY AGAIN AS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN A SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
WELL THANK YOU JOSEPH ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR THIRTY THREE WELCOME
CHAPTER TO KIA UP IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
SACRAMENTO RECIDIVISM I'VE SEEN
WHAT'S GOING ON THE CHARLIE ANY
OTHERS.
AND NOT ONE BY THE OPPOSITION AS
BEFORE THIRTY THREE PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
HERE'S THEY CLOSE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS
DANIEL SANCHEZ WITH THE CHEAP
PROBATION OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA
I'M HERE TODAY IN AND RESPECTFUL --
OPPOSITION I DO WANT TO JUST
THINK A CENTER MONNING AND IS
STAFF FOR ONGOING DIALOGUE --
OLDER FOR MY TIME OVER TO YOU --
CHIEF JIM SALLY ILL -- FOR
TESTIMONY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON -- JIM
SALLY -- CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY AND
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT.
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
BUT I FIRST WANT TO THANK US
UNDERMINE FOR BEING A PARTNER.
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
AND OVER THE YEARS AND AND TWO
BOXES OF VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CENTER
HAS OFFICE ON THIS BILL.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY AS BEFORE
THIRTY THREE REPRESENTS AN
APPROACH WE ARE IN OPPOSITION.
TO WE SHARED WITH THE SENATOR
OUR AGREEMENT WITH HIM THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT AND
COMMUNITY FACTORS THAT PLAY SOME
CHILDREN RISK A VERY IMPORTANT
IN PD AND NEED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
FACTORS SUCH AS PROBERT POVERTY
TRAUMA ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES HUNGER ARE.
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
AND IF ADDRESSED EARLY THEY CAN
LIVE A CONTACT WITH OUR
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AND THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THE AREA WHERE WE DISAGREE ON
THE APPROACH ARE THE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT COMBINED EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT.
AND THE VERSION UNDER NEW COUNTY
ENERGY PROVIDED FOR UP PROVIDING
THESE DIVERSION SERVICES OVER
THE YEARS PROBATION HAS INVESTED
IN DIVERSION AND BUILD LINKAGES
AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH DECADES.
OF THROUGH THE DECADES WITH
OTHER COUNTY DEPARTMENTS.
AND OTHER COMMUNITY GROUPS.
WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT DATA SHOW A
PRECIPITOUS DECLINE IN YOUTH
JUVENILE JUSTICE INVOLVEMENT.
AND WE ALL HAVE LOCAL COMMUNITY --
AT JUVENILE JUSTICE PLANS THAT
DO SPELL OUT HOW DIVERSION
SHOULD BE HANDLED AND HOW --
CLOBBERED SHOULD BE HELD IN THE
COUNTIES.
OUR OUR PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
EVALUATED TO DETERMINE TO BE
EVIDENCE BASED.
THE TO AND SET OF SERVICES A NEW
AND SHE WOULD BE MOVING FORWARD
WITH FROM PROGRAMS -- OUTCOMES
THAT WE KNOW ALREADY WORK.
SET UP A NEW COUNTY AND IS HE TO
FOCUS ON DIVERSION WOULD BE
SIMILAR.
TO IN THE NATURE TO HAVING TO
STATE AGENCIES WITH THE SAME
MISSION RESPONSIBILITIES.
INSTEAD THE BILL SHOULD FOCUS
EFFORTS NOT UNDER VERSION BUT ON
THE SYSTEM THAT NEED SUPPORT TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF YOUTH --
WERE DIVERSION BECOMES NECESSARY.
AGAIN WE WE BELIEVE THE
COMBINING DIVERSION.
WITH OTHER YOUTH DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS UNDER NEWLY CREATED
COUNTY AND TO YOU WOULD BE TWO
PARALLEL TRACKS. FOR DIVERSION
SERVICES WHICH WOULD TURN INTO --
COMPLICATED -- COMPLICATED
SERVICES TO YOUTH AND COMPLEXITY
THE PROGRAM SERVICE DELIVERY.
INSTEAD OF A BILL THAT FOCUS ON
THE FRONT END USED DEVELOPMENT.
AND STILL MET THE INTO THE GOALS
OF THE AUTHOR WHICH IS TO
ADDRESS ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCE IS THE BEST COURSE
FOR THIS REASON WE OPPOSE THE
BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION -- PLEASE COME
FORWARD -- SING AND I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE OPPOSITION THIS
IS A THE VOLUNTARY -- PILOT
PROGRAM -- YOU HAVE A MONOPOLY
ON HELPING THESE USE LIKE WE
HAVE THE YOUNG MAN THAT WISH
THAT WE HAD A SERVICE LIKE THIS
A CUT OF REBOUNDED HIM FROM
HAVING FURTHER CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
NO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THOUGH
THAT OUR DIVERSIONS SERVICES
THAT WE ARE SUPPLYING THE COUNTY
ART THERE AND CONTINUE TO
PROSPER -- HAVING COMPETING
SERVICES WITH THE COUNTY JUST TO
ME IS.
COMPLICITOUS AND NOT NEEDED IN
IN AN ACCOUNT THAT HAS PROVIDE I
MEAN WE WORK WITH SOCIAL
SERVICES WITH MENTAL HEALTH WITH
OTHER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ALL THE TIME AND
THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE DO A
DIVERSION -- TO CREATE A
GOVERNMENT ENTITY WHEN WE
ALREADY HAVE A GOVERNMENT AND
SEEING PROBATION.
UNDERTAKING DIVERSION IS NOT
NEEDED.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR ANSWERS.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OF CENTERS [inaudible]
SENATOR PAN.
THE CEREMONY I'D APPRECIATE YEAH
YEAH YEAH -- YOU I TAKE A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH -- ON THIS ISSUE
AND AND I THINK YOU'LL CERTAINLY
WE SHARE YOUR GOAL OF TRYING.
TO KEEP YOU FROM HAVING.
TO ESSENTIALLY ENTERED THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH THE
CONSEQUENCE IS THAT BEEN
DESCRIBED -- THE WITH A SAID
DESCRIBED IS WHAT.
WHERE DO YOU SEE AND THIS AGAIN
THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM WITH THE
OFFER FOR COUNTIES ARE
INTERESTED IN?
SO WHAT DO YOU SEE THE ROLE FOR
PROBATION I I'LL TELL YOU THAT
CERTAINLY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY I THINK -- WE'VE A VERY
INNOVATIVE PROBATION -- CHIEF
AND THE DEPARTMENT THAT ACTUALLY
MY OFFICE IS WORKING VERY
CLOSELY ON THE TRY TO ADDRESS.
THESE VERY ISSUES SO I GUESS I'M
TRAIL.
AND YET SINCE I WAS A READER
BILLS LIKE WILD MEAN SACRAMENTO
REALLY TRY COULD PARTICIPATE IF
PROBATION WAS INVOLVED SO CAN
YOU MAYBE SPEAKER OUT WHAT HOW.
DOES GIVEN THE I KNOW WE WHAT
TAKE A PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH OF
LEGALLY IN PUBLIC HEALTH I KNOW
YOU ARE TOO HOW HOW LONG WHAT WE
DO WITH THE I MEAN. FOR SOLAR
AFTER REPLACE THE EXISTING
PROBATION PART OF BUT I GUESS
WHAT WHAT WHAT DO YOU SEE.
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
INNOVATIVE THAT ALSO HAVE
EXPERIENCE DOING THAT SITTING IN
WITH YOUR ID WITH YOUR I GUESS
YOUR PROPOSAL WHEN I APPRECIATE
THE QUESTION AND THROUGH THE
CHAIR -- RESPONDING BUT YOUR
QUESTION I THINK SOME OF THE
CONCERNS.
RAISED BY A CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS SALLY -- WHO WE HAVE
HAD A GOOD WORKING RELATIONSHIP
IN SAN LUIS OBISPO COUNTY?
I THINK WE'RE JUST LOOKING AT
THIS THROUGH SOME DIFFERENT
LENSES IN MY VIEW VOLUNTARY
PILOT PROGRAM YOU GET MORE
RESOURCES INTO A COUNTY. TO TO
CREATE GREATER COLLABORATION
REMEMBER THIS IS DESIGNED.
MERELY TO IDENTIFY AND WORK WITH
USE BEFORE THEIR INTO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
PROBATION HAS BEEN DOING
INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THEY DO WORK
WITH DIVERSION PROGRAMS.
OUR BILL DOESN'T STOP.
ESTABLISH PROBATION PROGRAMS IN
ANY FASHION WE WOULD THINK THESE
PILOTS WOULD BE LABORATORIES FOR
GREATER COLLABORATION BUT
BRINGING IN.
IN A MORE DIRECTED MANNER --
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES IN BEING PART OF THAT
GREATER INTENTIONAL
COLLABORATION.
PRE ARREST -- WORKING WITH
SCHOOLS IDENTIFYING AT RISK
YOUTH.
THE BEAUTY OF THE LA PROGRAM
EVEN NOW IT'S IN ITS INFANCY IS
HAVING TREMENDOUS SUCCESS AS WE
HEARD FROM THE WITNESSES WE
THINK THAT PROVIDES A MODEL THAT
THOSE WHO VOLUNTARILY WOULD
ELECT. TO TRY A PILOT PROGRAM IN
THEIR COUNTY ARE NECESSARILY
GOING.
TO CORDONING COLLABORATE WITH
PROBATION DEPARTMENT BUT ALSO
THE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ESTABLISHING.
IT OUT SIDE OF THE UMBRELLA
PROBATION IS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PUTTING IT OUTSIDE OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM DOES NOT
MEAN YOU CAN'T CORDONING
COLLABORATE WITH PROBATION.
AND IF IT IS THROUGH THE CHAIR
IF I MIGHT ALSO JUST ASK OUR
EXPERT FROM NEW YORK LAWCENTER
IF SHE MIGHT WANT TO ADD TO THAT
RESPONSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AB.
SO YEAH I WOULD IT IN RESPONSE
TO YOUR QUESTION CENTER I THINK
THAT -- THEY'RE DEFINITELY I
THINK I WOULD JUST ECHO WHAT THE
CENTER SAID THERE IS A PLACE FOR
PROBATION TO CONTINUE DOING THE
WORK THE GOOD WORK THE PROBATION
IS ALREADY DOING.
THIS IS TARGETING YOUTH PRE
ARREST THERE IS NUMEROUS STUDIES
THAT SHOW THAT THE FURTHER A
CHILD OR YOUTH GOES THROUGH THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM STARTING
AT A REST.
THE FURTHER THE HARMS THAT
HAPPENED AND SO THIS BILL REALLY
IS TRYING TO TARGET WHAT
BASICALLY THE QUESTION IS WHY
SHOULD YOU HAVE TO GET ON
PROBATION TO GET SERVE SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS.
THAT THEY SHOULDN'T THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO GET THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS IN THEIR COMMUNITY IF
THEY HAPPEN TO GET ARRESTED AND
GET ON PROBATION AND CAN GET
THOSE SERVICES AND SUPPORTS
THROUGH PROBATION.
THAT'S GREAT BUT BEFORE THAT.
THE KIDS THROUGHOUT DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES DON'T HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS TO SERVICES IMPORTS IF
YOU LOOK AT WHILE THE
COMMUNITIES THERE ARE WAY MORE
SERVICES SUPPORTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR TO YOUTH.
THAT ARE NOT SIMILARLY SITUATED
IN POOR COMMUNITIES WHAT LA
COUNTY HAS DONE.
THEY DID A LANDSCAPE ANALYSIS TO
SEE WHERE ARE THE SERVICES IN
THE PORTS AND WHERE DO THEY NEED
TO BE AND THIS OFFICE OF YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT DIVERSION WOULD BE
COORDINATING THOSE SERVICES
SUPPORTS.
SPECIFICALLY THROUGH A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH -- WITHOUT
HAVING THE HARMS OF SYSTEM
INVOLVEMENT SO THAT'S REALLY THE
CRUX OF IT I AM IF THAT ANSWERS
YOUR QUESTION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY IS IS THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATOR --
JUST A QUICK QUESTION MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM.
SO WHY WOULD YOU BE OPPOSED TO
IT.
THE PROBATION BARBARA PROBATION
STONE A GREAT JOB AND EVERYTHING.
WHAT WHY WOULD YOU BE OPPOSED TO
THIS?
OTHER POSSIBILITY -- OR YOU
DON'T HAVE TO DO IT AT ALL.
IF YOU THINK YOU'RE DOING A
GREAT JOB THEN YOU DON'T NEED TO
AGREE TO DO THIS PROGRAM THAT'S
WHAT HAS ME PUZZLED.
AND I KNOW THERE'S OPPOSITION TO
A BUT I DON'T I DON'T GET IT
SOME OF YEAH I I I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION I THINK --
PART OF THE CONCERN REALLY IN MY
APOLOGIES.
FOR SINGLE -- I THINK PART OF
THE CONCERN IS ABOUT --
OBVIOUSLY I WE SHARE THE FOCUS
TO BREAK DOWN SILOS IN THIS
REGARD AND TO BUILD THE
COLLABORATIONS -- MANY OF WHICH
PROBATION IS DONE WITH WITH OUR
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND SO I
THINK THERE'S A A VERY -- REAL
OPERATIONAL CONCERN THAT BY.
RATHER THAN USING THE EXISTING
KIND OF COUNTY INFRASTRUCTURE TO
BUILD THOSE LINKAGES LOCALLY
AMONG ALL THE COUNTY DEPARTMENTS
IS SETTING UP.
A KIND OF NEW OFFICE -- THAT
WOULD HAVE THAT WOULD HAVE SHARE
SOME OF THE MISSION WITH
PROBATION BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT.
OFTEN IS OVERLOOKED IS THE
EXTENSIVE WORK THAT PROBATION
DOES NOT JUST ON THE YOUTH ONCE
THEY COME TO US AND DIVERTING
THEM OUT OF OUR HOLES THE REALLY
TO DO A LOT OF THAT EARLY
INTERVENTION AND PREVENTION
WORKS -- TO TO PROVIDE SOME OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES SUPPORTS
BEFORE THEY'RE ACTUALLY --
COMING TO US ON A PETITION AND
SO AGAIN I THINK THE CONCERN IS
THAT WE DO YOU SET UP AGAIN
SIMILAR TO KIND OF HAVING TO
STATE AGENCIES -- HAVING A
SHARED MISSION THAT.
WITH THE INTENT TO BREAK DOWN
SILOS THAT ACTUALLY CREATE MORE
ISSUES OF SERVING YOUTH IN WHAT
CAPACITY AND HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE IN USE THAT ARE.
NOT BEING SERVED AS A RESULT OF
THOSE CONCURRENT PROCESS BUT IF
YOU HAVE THESE CONCERNS YOU
DON'T HAVE TO DO THIS.
IS THAT RIGHT IT THE CHOICE
WOULD BE UP TO A COUNTY -- SO IS
PRESUMABLY THE COUNTIES GOING TO
COORDINATE.
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT WITH
PROBATION WITH OTHERS TO
DETERMINE WE WANT TO TRY THIS
AGAIN.
MY RESPONSE WOULD BE.
IF THE COUNTY WANTS TO TRY THE
PILOT CAN DRAW MORE RESOURCES TO
ASSIST THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF
RESOURCES.
IF IF PROBATION THINKS THEY HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES THAT ARE BEING RAISED --
I WOULD.
ASKED TO SEE.
HOW THEY'RE BEING DIRECTED TO
PRE ARREST YOUTH IN THESE
DIVERSION PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CONTEMPLATED AGAIN VOLUNTARY
PILOT?
WHAT PRACTICES DO WE LEARN WE
WOULD HOPE PROBATION IN THE
COUNTIES THAT WANT TO OPT IN?
IN BE GIVEN A CHANCE WOULD
EMBRACE IT AS AN OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU THE CENTER.
AS OUR MOTION.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
JACKSON WHICH ARE TO CLOSE IN
THE MONEY I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION I
WOULD URGE YOUR AYE VOTE AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY
COLLEAGUE SOME PROBATION I LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONTINED -- TO
COLLABORATION AND WORK ON THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS IS A DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS A CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
RICARDO STONE BY STONE I FELL.
BILL I JACKSON.
JACKSON I CAN WHY PAN AYE WIENER.
FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO ORDERLY THE
ROLE OF IN THE CENTER MONEY.
US SENATOR WINNERS -- STILL TIED
UP IN ANOTHER HEARING SO WITH --
THE COMMITTEE'S CONCURRENCE I'D
LIKE TO PRESENT MY SP.
FOUR ONE TWO AND SENATOR BILL.
AND YOU WANT TO SHARE.
SIR SORRY OF THE FOUR THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HONORABLE.
MEMBERS.
I'M VERY HAPPY TO PRESENT SB
FOUR ONE TWO THE LAND FROM AN
ACT THIS CALIFORNIA'S PROMISE TO
SERVE PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
VERY WELL OVER THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS ARE PART OF
THE SERVICE SYSTEM.
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE THEIR HEART
CORDONING SERVICES IN A
CONNECTING FAMILIES TO THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED.
DURING THE GREAT RECESSION THE
SUFFERED MANY SUFFERED MANY CUTS
AS WELL AS FEES IMPOSED ON
FAMILIES.
THESE THESE REALLY SHOULD BE
CALLED DISABILITY TAXES BECAUSE
THEY ARE A BARRIER BETWEEN
CHILDREN AND THE SERVICES THEY
NEED INCLUDING SERVICES THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY VALUABLE TO DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES.
THEY ALSO HURT WHAT IS MEANT TO
BE A COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN CENTERS AND THOSE THAT
THEY SERVE.
SB FOUR ONE TWO REPEAL TWO OF
THESE FEES THE FAMILY COST
PARTICIPATION PROGRAM AND THE
ANNUAL FAMILY PROGRAM FEE.
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS REYES
LITTLE MONEY AND FORCE RESOURCE
CENTER TO SPEND TIME AND
RESOURCES.
FOCUSED ON COLLECTING MONEY
INSTEAD OF COORDINATING AND
DELIVERING SERVICES BY REPEALING
THEM WE COULD REMOVE THESE
BARRIERS TO SERVICE FOR CHILDREN
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
TODAY WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR ONE TWO IS
AMY WESTLING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF ARCA.
AND JENNIFER BLOOM WHO WORKS FOR
ALL THE CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
CENTER.
WELCOME LADIES OF MY WHEN THIS
IS A TWO WAY RACE IS PLEASE.
YES MY NAME IS AMY WESTLING I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES AND
I WANT TO FIRST THANK SENATOR
STONE FOR YOUR ON GOING SUPPORT
OF PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
AS WELL AS EXTEND MY GRATITUDE
TO COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF THIS BILL.
AS SENATOR STONE NOTED THE
FAMILY BECAUSE PARTICIPATION
PROGRAM REQUIRES REGIONAL
CENTERS TO ASSESS CHILDREN'S
NEEDS FOR FAMILY SUPPORT
SERVICES.
INCLUDING RESPITE IN DAY CARE
AND THEN TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
SERVICES THEY FUND FOR SOME
CHILDREN IN RESPONSE TO FAMILY
INCOME.
THE ANNUAL FAMILY PROGRAM FOR
YOU.
REQUIRES MANY PARENTS OF INFANTS
TODDLERS AND CHILDREN SIR BY
REGIONAL CENTERS TO PAY A FEE TO
THE STATE BECAUSE THEY ACCESS.
NEEDED SERVICES FOR THEIR
CHILDREN WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
IN RESPONSE PROGRAM'S REGIONAL
CENTERS HAVE SEEN FAMILIES
DECLINING OR POSTPONING SERVICE.
FOR THEIR CHILDREN IN.
POSTPONING SERVICES THEIR
CHILDREN NEED.
IN RESPONSE TO THE FEES A MOVE
THAT IN THE LONG RUN LEAVES
CHILDREN REQUIRING MORE COSTLY
STATE FUNDED SERVICES.
DEPENDING ON INCOME THE FEE IS
EITHER ONE HUNDRED FIFTY OR TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER YEAR WHICH
MAIN SEEM SMALL BUT IS
UNATTAINABLE FOR MANY AND MAYBE
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A CHILD
ACCESSING SERVICES AND NOT. ONE
OF THE PRIMARY DROPS OF REGIONAL
CENTERS IS TO MAKE THE LIVES OF
FAMILIES THAT HAVE CHILDREN WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
EASIER.
THESE POLICIES FOR SOME TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR CHILDREN'S
DEVELOPMENTAL NEEDS AND OTHER
CRITICAL FAMILY MR CITIES.
BOTH PROGRAMS WERE ESTABLISHED
AT A TIME WHEN THE STATE WAS
FACING BUDGETARY CHALLENGES.
AND THE PROGRAMS WERE SHORT
SIGHTED SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE LED
TO FAMILIES FOR GOING SERVICES
THAT THEY AND THEIR CHILDREN
NEED.
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO JENNIFER BLOOM TO PROVIDE
SOME REAL WORLD EXAMPLES.
HELLO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY -- I AND MY NAME IS
JENNIFER BLOOM I'M FROM ALTA
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL CENTER I AM
A CLIENT SERVICES MANAGER OF A
CHILDREN'S UNIT SERVING CHILDREN
AGES -- THREE TO EIGHTEEN BEEN
DOING THAT FOR FOUR YEARS AND
PRIOR TO THAT I WAS A SERVICE
COORDINATOR IN THE CHILDREN'S
UNIT FOR SEVEN YEARS.
I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE TO BE IN
THE FAMILY HOME IN ASKING
FAMILIES FOR THEIR TAX RETURNS
AND IT'S VERY INTRUSIVE --
FAMILIES ARE RESISTANT TO
PROVIDE THEIR TAX RETURNS TO THE
REGIONAL CENTER THAT'S PRIVATE
INFORMATION SO IT'S
UNCOMFORTABLE FOR MANY FAMILIES
TO DO SO -- AND WE FOUND IN.
IN THAT THAT FAMILY SOMETIMES
WILL DECLINE SERVICES ARE FOR
GROWTH SERVICES BECAUSE OF THEIR
ARE ASSESSED A FEE AS AMY STATED
THEY MAY NOT FIND THAT THAT FEE
FITS INTO THEIR BUDGET.
AND THEN THEY MAY DECLINE
SERVICES THAT WE HAVE ASSESSED.
I NEED.
FOR SO -- YOU KNOW WE HAVE SEEN
THAT TO BE A DETERRENT --
FAMILIES.
YOU KNOW.
WE DON'T WANT THEM TO BE MAKING
DECISIONS ON SERVICES FOR THEIR
CHILD BASED UPON A FEE.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THAT HAPPEN.
OF OTHER TESTIMONY IN FAVOR
PLEASE.
THIS IS IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL SB --
FOUR ONE TWO OCCURS WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
IT WHAT ELSE WAS RECOVERING.
AND CHAPTER TO GEAR IN SUPPORT
AS PART OF THE COALITION.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OF OPPONENTS -- SPEAKERS
OPPONENT POSING THIS BILL.
SB [inaudible]
FOUR ONE TWO SAY NOT.
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WELL.
THERE'S A MOTION FOR THE BILL
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF IF NOT.
YOU MAY CLOSE CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- WE
CERTAINLY CAN UNDERSTAND WHEN
THE SEAS WERE OR IMPOSE IT WAS
IN THE STATE WAS IN A DIFFERENT
ECONOMIC TIME AS WE'VE SEEN THIS
IS A BARRIER. TO PROVIDING
CHILDREN WITH THE NEEDED
SERVICES THAT THEY THEY NEED AND
DESERVE AND FOR THOSE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND WILL CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE [inaudible]
RICARDO.
ACTUALLY FIRST SB.
FOUR TWELVE AM SENATORS DOWN THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATION HURTADO.
STONE BY STONE HI BEL BEL AYE
JACKSON.
PAN PAN AYE WIENER [inaudible]
THREE ZERO ZERO LEAVE LEAVE THE
ROLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] FOR MORE.
WE WANT OUR YEAH.
HI YEAH THE SERVER.
WHEN CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS?
ITEM TWO SP ONE SIXTY THREE
SENATOR POURED INTO PORTANTINO
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
HURTADO [inaudible]
JACKSON.
A WINNER.
OF THE DIXIE I'M SORRY.
HURTADO JACKSON PAN HI PAN HI
WIENER.
SO THAT NOW HAS THREE BOATS --
SB ONE SEVENTY TWO PORTANTINO.
I'M THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS -- THE
CURRENT LOTUS. TWO TO ONE
HURTADO -- JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE WIENER.
SO THAT YES WE GO BACK TO TO
AGAIN FOR SENATOR.
AND A SECOND.
YES.
I DON'T WANT.
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS JACKSON.
JACKSON HI.
THAT HAS FOR VOTE THANK YOU --
ONE SEVENTY TWO WITHOUT.
SB M. -- ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE WIENER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS.
ON THAT ONE I'M SORRY OKAY YEAH
RIGHT.
SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR GLAZER.
THE MOTION IS D. PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RETIRO JACKSON.
JACKSON.
JACKSON HI WIENER.
LAST FOUR VOTES NOW.
WE DO WITH THE CONSENT.
YES WE DID WE HOPE WILL ORDER
AGAIN ARE YOU.
IN.
SB FOR TWELVE STONE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS HURTADO JACKSON.
JACKSON I WIENER SO NOW IT HAS
FOR VOTE.
SB FOUR THIRTY THREE MINING --
I'M GONNA PASS BY BECAUSE
EVERYONE IS VOTED HE'S CURRENTLY
PRESENT.
SB -- FOUR NINETY HURTADO -- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER.
SO THAT HAS FIVE VOTES
[inaudible]
SB.
WHAT I'M SIX FOURTEEN RUBIO?
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
HURTADO JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE PAN.
HI CAN I WIENER.
THAT HAS FOUR VOTES.
SB SIX NINETY FIVE PORTANTINO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE --
HURTADO JACKSON.
ALL RIGHT JACKSON AYE AND VOTED
AND THE WINNER.
SO THAT HAS THAT HAS FOUR VOTES
CURRENTLY.
WE DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR YES.
SYNC CALENDAR.
SO THAT FOR SB TO TWENTY TWO
SENATOR JACKSON THE MOTION.
JUST A SECOND PLEASE THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AND THE WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
TO CONSENT -- ITEM NINE SB FORCE
THIRTY SIX FURTADO THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO CONSENT.
ITEM TEN SP FOUR FIFTY THREE HER
TADO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
WHAT AM I AM WITH?
AS WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SP FOUR SEVENTY SKINNER
THE MOTION IS D. PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND SB SEVEN THIRTY FIVE LEYVA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- PAN.
PAN AYE WIENER RIGHT WIENER AYE
THAT HAS SIX VOTES GREAT.
CENTER WINNER WE'VE GOT YOU IT
SB.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE AND THEN AFTER
THAT WILL CALL THE ROLL FOR YOU
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible] TO I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- THE COLORS ARE
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY FIVE SIX
TO INCREASE.
CALIBRATION ROLE MEN'S
ACCESSIBILITY TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ARE BY CREATING A
STATE AND COUNTY PARTNERSHIP TO
SIR CLEAR AND A CALAVERAS
ACCOUNTABLE STATEWIDE ENROLLMENT
GOALS.
IT'S SIMPLE AND EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO ENROLLMENT FOR ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS.
AND TO REMOVE BARRIERS TO THE
CALIBRATION ROMAN PROCESS.
SPECIFICALLY SB -- TWO EIGHTY
FIVE SUCH AMBITIOUS BUT
ACHIEVABLE PARTICIPATION GOALS.
STARTING WITH THE PLAN TO ENROLL
AT LEAST 75% OF NEWLY ELIGIBLE
SSI RECIPIENTS WITHIN THE FIRST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
OF THE ELIGIBILITY EXPANSION AND
AIMING TO REACH 95% STATEWIDE
ENROLLMENT WITHIN FIVE YEARS --
IT WILL ENSURE THE CLIENTS CAN
STORE AND COMPLETE THE
APPLICATION PROCESS.
BY PHONE ONLINE IN PERSON OR BY
MAIL REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY
LIVE FOR THEIR INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IT WILL DIRECT THE STATE TO
PROVIDE TIMELY AND ACCURATE
TRANSLATIONS OF IT AN
INTERPRETATION TO ENSURE.
EQUITABLE ACCESS FOR NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS.
I WILL DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT A
SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
IT WILL ENSURE AVAILABLE AND
RELEVANT DATA IS COLLECTED AND
MADE AVAILABLE FOR EQUITY
ANALYSIS TO INFORM PROGRAM
IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS.
AND IT WILL CREATE A STATEWIDE
MULTI PROGRAM PORTAL TO APPLY TO
NOT JUST CAL FRESH BUT CALPERS
MEDI CAL CAL WORKS IN WITH FOR
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION.
LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE
CURRENTLY GOOD IN CIRCLES IF
YOU'D GOOD AND SECURE.
IN CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA IS
AMONG THE LOWEST PERFORMING
STATES IN TERMS OF CONNECTING
HOUSEHOLDS.
THE FEDERAL FOOD ASSISTANCE WITH
THREE IN TEN ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS
NOT RECEIVING THE BENEFITS A
CALPERS WHICH IS OUR LARGEST AND
MOST IMPACTFUL ANTI HUNGER
PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA RANKS FOURTH TO LAST
THE NUMBER FORTY SEVEN IN
CONNECTING WORKING POOR
HOUSEHOLDS AND AND RANKS LAST IN
CONNECTING SENIORS TO A CALPERS
PROGRAM.
DESPITE RECENT CHANGES CHANGES
TO THE ENROLLMENT PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA STILL FAILS TO REACH
FOUR OUT OF FIVE ELIGIBLE
SENIORS.
A LARGE BODY OF EVIDENCE
SUGGESTS THAT THE FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S TO REACH ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE IS DUE TO ADMINISTRATIVE
DESIGN THAT DOES NOT CONSIDER
THE COGNITIVE EMOTIONAL AND
ATTENTIONAL COSTS THAT PEOPLE
WITH FINANCIAL INSTABILITY FACE.
ALL ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY LIVE --
OR THE LIFE CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD
BE ABLE TO ACCESS HELLO FRESH
WITH EASE.
I UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THIS IS A
BILL THAT -- THERE'S BEEN SOME
PUSH BACK BECAUSE IN YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A IS GOING TO
TAKE SOME WORK WE UNDERSTAND
IT'S NOT.
EASY TO INCREASE -- THE
ENROLLMENT FOR CALIBRATION BUT
IT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO
CALIFORNIA HAS SUCH A LOW UPTAKE
ON CALPERS.
SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE IS SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY
ADVOCATES A. R. P..
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS AND THE SAN FRANCISCO
MARIN FOOD BANK.
WE ARE BROAD SUPPORT AMONG OF
THE FOOD ACCESS COMMUNITY.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY OR TRACY
PATTERSON FROM CALIFORNIA TO
POLICY ADVOCATES AND FRANCESCA
ACOSTA FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
MARIN FOOD BANK.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE
THIS DOES ENJOY A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT SO IF YOU KEEP COMMENTS
FREE FED REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MANY SUCH
AS CUSTOMER COVER CHARGE PROGRAM
MANAGER WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO
MAN FOOD BANK -- ORGANIZATIONS
SERVES A HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE THROUGH VARIOUS METHODS
OF FOOD DISTRIBUTION EVERY WEEK --
BUT WE KNOW THAT WE CAN'T SOLVE
FOOD SECURITY ON OUR OWN -- AND
BECAUSE OF THIS WE HAVE A WHOLE
TEAM OF WHIPPING STAFF FOR
DEDICATED TO SUPPORTING THE
COVERS APPLICATION PROCESS.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR A STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR COUNTY --
AND OKAY LEADERSHIP HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
CALL FRESH -- I HAVE DEDICATED
SIX YEARS TO WORKING ON THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE I KNOW --
FIRSTHAND THAT IT'S A VALUABLE
LIFE LINE FOR PEOPLE FACING VENN
SECURITY -- UPSET WITH FOLKS WHO
SHARED YOUR BILL HUGS AT THE
REALIZATION THAT THEY WOULD HAVE --
TO DOLLARS EXTRA IN THEIR BUDGET
FOR FOOD.
AND I'VE ALSO SET OF PEOPLE SO
FRUSTRATED BY THE PROCESS THAT
THEY GIVE UP ENTIRELY -- IS A
LOSS NOT JUST FOR THEM BUT FOR
THEIR FAMILIES -- FOR CALIFORNIA
THAT SICKENING -- DESPITE
EVERYONE'S BEST EFFORTS MANY
CLIENTS ARE STILL DENIED FOR
PROCEDURAL RASONS A MISSING AN
INTERVIEWER ONE ADDITIONAL
DOCUMENTS THAT CAN START THEM AT
SQUARE.
ONE OR IN A PIVOTAL MOMENT FOR
THIS PROGRAM GIVEN THAT WE'RE
EXPANDING ACCESS TO FOLKS WITH
DISABILITIES AND SENIORS WHO ARE
LOW INCOME -- AND THIS MAY
POTENTIALLY WITH THEM OUT OF
POVERTY VERY CRUCIAL MOMENT AND
WE KNOW THAT FOR MANY PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE SSI -- PROVIDING
ACCESSIBLE OPTIONS LIKE BEING
OVER ABLE TO APPLY OVER THE
PHONE IS CRUCIAL -- THANKFULLY
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS POSSIBLE
BECAUSE WE'VE DONE IT WITH
MEDICAL AND SO -- AT TWENTY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS THANK YOU FOR YOUR PASSION
AND A GOOD WORK IN SAN FRANCISCO
APPRECIATED THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
HI AND THANKS TRACY PATTERSON
CALIFORNIA FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES --
KEEP THIS VERY BRIEF -- WE'RE
JUST REALLY THRILLED THAT CENTER
WINNERS INTRODUCED THIS THIS IS
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF PROGRESSIVE
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM RFORM THAT
WE NEED -- WE HAVE NUMEROUS WORK
GROUPS AT THE STATE LEVEL WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT HORIZONTAL
INTEGRATION FOR YEARS WORKING ON
THE PORTAL -- THIS REALLY IS THE
TIME THAT WE CAN MAKE CHANGE
THAT WILL LAST FOR DECADES AGO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY OF
CALLING THE OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
BOTTOM.
THANKS.
I'M REBEKAH COUSINS ON THE
VOLUNTEER FROM CALIFORNIA OUR
PAN BECAUSE SPONSORED THIS BILL
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT IT THANK
YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MAKE DAVID'S IN SAN FRANCISCO
MARIN FOOD BANK AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE FOR EVERY ONE
MEAL WE CAN PUT OUT AS A FOOD
BANK YOU CAN GET TWENTY OUT OF
CAL FRESH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JEFF TURNED A KIA IS A A CAL
FRESH COALITION STAKEHOLDER AND
PARTICIPATING THIS LAST YEAR
GETTING THIS THE ONLY THING I
WOULD SAY YOU WIENER.
IS GET BACK SOME REPORTS SO
YOU'LL KNOW WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING THAT WOULD BE A
SUGGESTION TO YOU WOULD SEE THAT
YOU GET.
SOMETHING SO YOU CAN HOLD A
THIRD DEGREE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
ON THIS BUT PLEASE SUPPORT.
SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU.
AND A CHAIN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
THIS ONE I THINK -- CENTER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND AS AS
JUST FOR YOU TO JUST MENTION
YOUR ON THE PRECIPICE OF THIS
HISTORIC EXPANSION OF COVERAGE
FOR HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
SENIORS AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES
ON SSI. TO KNOW TRULY IS THE
TIME AS TRACY SAID FOR US TO
MAKING THE SYSTEM EXPANSIONS
MAKEUP BRUSH WORK FOR EVERYONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
TESTIMONY OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
ANYBODY OPPOSED TO SB
[inaudible]
TWO EIGHTY FIVE SAYING THAT --
SENATOR JACKSON'S MOVE THE BILL
ON A JUST A FAKE AGAIN THE
WITNESSES FROM ME FOR FOUR FOUR
EDIFY SENIORS I MEAN THAT'S JUST
AN APPALLING FIGURE -- SENATOR
WIENER THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD AND IN FILLING THAT
VOID OF PEOPLE THAT -- GO TO BED
HUNGRY EVERY NIGHT AND SHOULD BE
GOING TO BED HUNGRY EVERY NIGHT
AND IN KEEPING WITH OUR
TRADITION THIS YEAR I'D LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR I THINK
SPIKE THE NUMBER SIX OR SEVEN
AND IT'S AN HONOR TO WORK WITH
YOU THIS YEAR SIR.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU CENTER THAT
WILL LOVE THIS GOING TO GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- UPON --
PASSING AND WE'LL JUST CALL THE
ROLL.
SB TWO EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR
WINNER THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HURTADO
STONE BY STONE HI BEL.
BELL I JACKSON JACKSON AYE PAN
ALL RIGHT CAN I WINNER RIGHT
WIENER HI -- HURTADO.
HURTADO HI.
THANK YOU SO WE CAN CALL THE
ROLL FOR SENATOR WIENER AND HER
TAUGHT OF THAT WOULD BE FABULOUS
[inaudible]
YES.
THE BILL IS OUT.
SIX ZERO THE ESPYS -- SB ONE
SIXTY THREE PORTANTINO --
CURRENTLY THERE FOR VOTE HERE
HAS NOT VOTED MOTION IS DO YOU
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HURTADO.
HER TITLE I WINNER.
WIENER AYE SIX SIX THE BILL IS
OUT.
SB ONE SEVENTY TWO PORTANTINO.
CURRENTLY THE VOTE IS -- THREE
ONE THE CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS A
MINUTE TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HURTADO.
HER TITLE HI WIENER.
WIENER AYE -- FIVE I WENT THAT'S
OUT.
SB SP -- THREE SEVENTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS D. PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED -- AB
HURTADO HER TITLE HI WIENER.
WIENER I SB FOR TWELVE HASSLE
WITH LASKO WITHOUT WITH BUT I'M.
I'M SORRY WITH SIX BY.
SIX YES SEVEN THAT BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
YES.
SB.
THREE SEVENTY FOUR YES OKAY SB
THREE SEVENTY FOUR NOW WITH
DENTAL SEVENTY FOUR I'M SORRY SB.
FOR TWELVE SENATOR STONE.
ON THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CHAIRS NOT VOTED -- HER TITLE.
RICARDO I AND WIENER RIGHT
WIENER I HAVE SIX VOTES AT THAT
BILL IS OUT -- SIX ZERO IT SB
FOUR THIRTY THREE MINING THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HURTADO.
HER TITLE AYE WIENER
[inaudible]
WIENER I THOSE OUT.
SIX ZERO SB -- FOUR NINETY
HURTADO THE MOTION IS DEEP
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE -- CHAIR VOTES I
WINNER.
WIENER I SIX VOTE THAT VOTE IS
OUT THE BILL THAT -- SIX ZERO SB
SIX FOURTEEN SENATOR RUBIO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CHAIR IS NOT VOTED HER TITLE.
HURTADO AYE WIENER.
WIENER I SIX VOTES THAT BILLS
OUT.
SIX ZERO AND SB SIX NINETY FIVE
PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
CHAIR IS NOT VOTED HER TITLE.
RICARDO HI.
AND WIENER.
WIENER -- AND IT HAS SIX VOTES
THAT BILLS OUT.
SIX ZERO OUR BY THE MOTION ON SB
TWO TWENTY EIGHT TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. TWO TWENTY EIGHT YES.
OKAY ALL RIGHT NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAN MANAGE YOUR FEEL BETTER.
AND WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK YOU